I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hello, everyone. Welcome to Sabre. Yes, it is season six, episode 15, written by Jennifer Salada, known to us as Jen Salada, and directed by John Krasinski. Yes, known to us as JK. Oh my gosh. John. Great job. I loved this episode.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们带来终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。你好。大家好。欢迎来到Sabre。没错，这是第六季第15集，由詹妮弗·萨拉达（我们称她为珍·萨拉达）编剧，约翰·卡拉辛斯基执导。没错，我们称他为JK。天哪。约翰。干得好。我喜欢这一集。
I did too. It was one of those sleeper ones that I hadn't watched in years. That I had forgotten about. Yeah, and I was cracking up. Oh my gosh. So many memories flooded back for me. All those daycare scenes. Oh, they were so good. Oh my gosh. I can't wait to talk about them. I can't wait to talk about them. And there's even more in the shooting draft that didn't make it in. So we're gonna share it all with you. Here's a summary. Dunder Mifflin has officially been bought by a new company. Sabre. Gabe Lewis, the new director of sales, arrives in Scranton and brings with him a list of changes and new company policies that do not sit well with Michael. Michael seeks advice
我也喜欢。这是那种我好几年没看过的冷门剧集。我都快忘了。是的，我当时笑得前仰后合。天哪。太多的回忆涌上心头。所有那些日托中心的场景。哦，它们太棒了。天哪。我迫不及待想谈谈它们了。我迫不及待想谈谈它们了。拍摄草稿里还有更多没被剪进去的内容。所以我们要和你们分享这一切。这是一个摘要。邓德·米夫林公司正式被一家新公司收购了。Sabre。新任销售总监盖博·刘易斯抵达斯克兰顿，带来了一系列变革和新公司政策，这让迈克尔很不高兴。迈克尔寻求建议
from a very unemployed David Wallace. Meanwhile, Pam and Jim tour a daycare center, and Aaron and Andy wait for the other to make a move. It is the most awkward courtship of two people. I was yelling at the TV screen. I was like, one of you just asked the other one out. They're making me crazy. We have so much stuff to share in this episode. I mean, I hope we can get through it all. We better get to it. But before we do, folks, I want you to know Jenna is wearing a poofy flower on her lapel today. Okay. I'm trying this. This is your book look. Oh, and our book is coming out in two weeks. In two weeks. Our book is launching into the world and we need a bunch of outfits, Angela. You know, I've been spending weeks and weeks
来自一位非常失业的大卫·华莱士。与此同时，帕姆和吉姆参观了一家日托中心，艾琳和安迪在等待对方采取行动。这是两个人之间最尴尬的求爱。我当时对着电视屏幕大喊。我说，你们俩谁去约对方出去啊。他们快把我逼疯了。我们在这一集里有太多东西要分享了。我的意思是，我希望我们能讲完。我们最好开始吧。但在我们开始之前，各位，我想让你们知道珍娜今天在翻领上戴了一朵蓬松的花。好吧。我在尝试这个。这是你的书本造型。哦，我们的书两周后就要出版了。两周后。我们的书即将推向世界，我们需要很多套服装，安吉拉。你知道，我花了几周又几周的时间
curating outfits because I am not naturally gifted in that area. I never want you to stop trying to put together outfits because now every day, and I'm talking, I mean, almost every day, I get a picture of you in front of your closet and you're like, what about this? I know. And so here's the problem I'm having. I declared that I was going to wear fake flowers. You sure did. You made a big declaration. And it's not working. I'm wearing one today because I wanted you to see. Hear me out. I'm going to stand up. Well, I want you to see what I think is happening here. And it's, I know it's the striped shirt, but I think it's the fake flower too. Are you ready? Yeah. What does this remind you
精心挑选服装，因为我在那方面没有天赋。我永远不希望你停止尝试搭配服装，因为现在每天，我是说，几乎每天，我都会收到一张你在衣橱前的照片，然后你会说，这件怎么样？我知道。这就是我遇到的问题。我宣布我要戴假花。你确实这么做了。你做了一个大声明。但这行不通。我今天戴了一朵，因为我想让你看看。听我说完。我要站起来。好吧，我想让你看看我认为发生了什么。我知道是条纹衬衫的问题，但我认为假花也有问题。你准备好了吗？是的。这让你想起了什么
of? Oh, yeah, you look like a French mime. I look like a Parisian mime. You do. Wait, I need a picture of you doing that. Oh my gosh. All right. Well, we're very excited. Our book is coming out in two weeks. We can't believe it. I can't promise I'm going to wear a fake flower every one. I'm sorry to disappoint. I'm still trying. You got to have one, Jenna. That's one. I'll work on it. All right. Let's get into fast facts. Fast fact number one, John Krasinski directed this episode. My gosh. We had a fan question from Alice R in Italy. No. How was it seeing John Krasinski on the other side of the camera as director? He did an amazing job. He sure did. He was just like a natural. He really was. It was a total
？哦，是的，你看起来像个法国哑剧演员。我看起来像个巴黎哑剧演员。你确实像。等等，我需要一张你那样做的照片。天哪。好吧，我们非常兴奋。我们的书两周后就要出版了。我们简直不敢相信。我不能保证我每天都会戴假花。很抱歉让你们失望了。我还在尝试。你得戴一朵，珍娜。那是一朵。我会努力的。好吧。让我们进入快速事实。快速事实一，约翰·卡拉辛斯基执导了这一集。天哪。我们收到了意大利Alice R的粉丝提问。不。看到约翰·卡拉辛斯基作为导演在摄像机另一边是什么感觉？他做得非常棒。他确实做到了。他就像个天生的人才。他真的是。这绝对是
pleasure. It was always tricky. What was it going to be like when one of our castmates stepped into directing, particularly because they had to be on both sides of the camera, like logistically. How does that work? Right. And John was your major scene partner. He was. It was so crazy how we could do scenes together and he would be completely in character as Jim. I felt like I was talking to Jim, but then we would cut and he would have simultaneously observed things and would have notes. I don't know how he did. I don't know how your brain does. My brain doesn't do that. Some people have that brain though. They just compartmentalize it and then they know how to like, I'm sort of a one trick pony. I know. I like to be
一种享受。这总是很棘手。当我们的演员伙伴转行做导演时会是什么样子，特别是考虑到他们必须在摄像机两边工作，从后勤角度来看。那是怎么运作的？没错。而约翰是你主要的对手戏演员。他是。我们能一起演戏，而他又能完全沉浸在吉姆的角色中，这太疯狂了。我觉得我是在和吉姆说话，但当我们喊停时，他同时观察到了事情并有笔记。我不知道他是怎么做到的。我不知道你的大脑是怎么运作的。我的大脑做不到。但有些人确实有那种大脑。他们只是将其分门别类，然后他们知道如何……我算是个只会一招的人。我知道。我喜欢
doing the one thing. The one thing. I'm real good at the one thing at one time. Well, we reached out to John and he's off right now filming season three of Jack Ryan, but he sent in some audio clips and we're so excited to share them with you. First off, he talked about what it was like to direct the show. Hi guys. Wait a minute. How are you on Saber already? That means that it is season six. You're into season six. No, slow down. We need more of this podcast. The world needs more of this podcast for the love of Pete. That's all I have to say about that. What was it like directing Saber? It was a dream. It was absolutely everything you would wish directing a show like this would be. I personally
做那一件事。那一件事。我一次只擅长做那一件事。好吧，我们联系了约翰，他现在正在拍摄《杰克·莱恩》第三季，但他发来了一些音频片段，我们非常兴奋能与你们分享。首先，他谈到了执导这部剧是什么感觉。嘿，伙计们。等等。你们怎么已经到Sabre了？这意味着这是第六季。你们进入第六季了。不，慢点。我们需要更多这个播客。为了上帝的爱，世界需要更多这个播客。关于这一点，我只想说这些。执导Sabre是什么感觉？那是一个梦想。这绝对是你希望执导这样一部剧所能拥有的一切。我个人
was terrified because I had to direct all of you. I remember being really, really nervous about that, that you were my coworkers, but you were my closest friends. You were my family. And here I was thinking I had the audacity to tell you what to do, which incidentally, I don't think I did once. I'm not sure I gave one acting note to any of you because I was just in awe watching, sitting back and watching, which really was one of the most special parts about directing the show was getting to see through a totally unique lens of being behind these monitors. The magic that every single one of you brought to each and every moment, whether it was a joke or whether it was an emotional beat, everyone
当时吓坏了，因为我必须执导你们所有人。我记得对此感到非常非常紧张，因为你们是我的同事，但你们是我最亲密的朋友。你们是我的家人。而我当时竟然认为我有胆量告诉你们该做什么，顺便说一句，我认为我一次都没做过。我不确定我是否给你们任何一个人提过表演建议，因为我只是敬畏地坐着观看，这确实是执导这部剧最特别的部分之一，那就是通过站在监视器后面的独特视角。你们每个人带给每一个瞬间的魔力，无论是笑话还是情感节奏，每个人
was just so good at what they did. And of course, as an actor, I always used to love watching everybody play in these scenes, but there were so many scenes that I wasn't a part of. So, you know, getting to in Saber, getting to be a part of the hot tub scene with Michael and David Wallace. At the end of the day, I think that directing that episode was a much bigger deal than I even understood or imagined then in that moment, because the truth is directing is terrifying. As I told you, I was very nervous to do it on this show. And honestly, if it hadn't been for this episode being such an amazing experience surrounded by such hugely supportive crew members, cast members, producers, everyone, I don't know
都非常擅长他们所做的事情。当然，作为一名演员，我过去总是喜欢看每个人在这些场景中表演，但有许多场景我没有参与。所以，你知道，在Sabre中，能参与迈克尔和大卫·华莱士的热水浴缸场景。归根结底，我认为执导那一集比我当时想象的要重要得多，因为事实是执导工作令人恐惧。正如我告诉你们的，我在这部剧上做这件事非常紧张。老实说，如果不是因为这一集是一次如此美妙的经历，周围有如此支持我的剧组成员、演员、制片人，每个人，我不知道
that I ever would have done it again. Truly. I mean, I think it was something that I was really excited to experiment with on our show, but never thought that I'd go much further than that in trying to direct anything else. Can you imagine? Oh, man. Could you imagine if he didn't keep directing? He's so good. I know. I just love that John got to have this experience on our show for the first time because you and I know how loving and supportive everyone was. This was true for other people as well. I mean, our editor, Claire Scanlon, has a very successful directing career in television. That started with the office. That was because Greg was very encouraging of having different department heads step into
我是否还会再做一次。真的。我的意思是，我认为这是我在我们的剧集上非常兴奋尝试的事情，但从未想过我会在这之外尝试执导其他任何东西。你能想象吗？天哪。你能想象如果他不继续执导吗？他太棒了。我知道。我只是喜欢约翰能在我们的剧集里第一次有这种经历，因为你和我都知道每个人是多么充满爱和支持。这对其他人也适用。我的意思是，我们的剪辑师克莱尔·斯坎伦在电视领域有着非常成功的导演生涯。那是从《办公室》开始的。这是因为格雷格非常鼓励不同的部门主管进入
that role of director to step out of what they were doing and try this new thing in a really supportive environment. I feel like it launched the directing careers of many people. Randall Eidhorn, our cinematographer. Matt Sohn. Yes. So many. And by the way, the writer of this episode, Jen Salada. Yeah. I was just watching television the other day. I was watching Abbott Elementary and she directed the episode. I was like, Oh my gosh, Jen. So many people. Well, listen, speaking of Jen Salada, there is a great interview with her and John over on office telly.com for this episode. I'll share some of what they talked about as we go along. But one of the things that it included were interviews with
导演的角色，走出他们正在做的事情，在一个非常支持的环境中尝试这个新事物。我觉得它开启了许多人的导演生涯。兰德尔·艾德霍恩，我们的摄影师。马特·索恩。是的。太多了。顺便说一句，这一集的编剧，珍·萨拉达。是的。我前几天还在看电视。我在看《小学风云》，她执导了那一集。我说，天哪，珍。太多人了。好吧，听着，说到珍·萨拉达，office telly.com上有一篇关于这一集的她和约翰的精彩采访。随着节目的进行，我会分享一些他们谈论的内容。但其中包含的一件事是采访了
cast members about John's directing. Oh, really? Yes. So I'm going to tell you what people said. All right. Ellie said, John made me feel confident yet calm and also made me laugh throughout the entire week. If it isn't too weird a thing to say, I feel like he took very good care of us. Oh, Brian said he was bold, which I thought was cool. He wanted characters to try new things. Kate said John was a very thoughtful director who created a great tone on set. He really did his homework on all levels. He took his job very seriously, but not himself. Like he didn't take himself seriously. That's John. And then Creed said, which one's John? Oh my gosh, Creed. Creed with the button. So perfect. All right. Fast
演员们关于约翰的执导。哦，真的吗？是的。所以我来告诉你们人们说了什么。好吧。艾莉说，约翰让我感到自信又冷静，并且在整个星期里都让我发笑。如果说这话不奇怪的话，我觉得他把我们照顾得很好。哦，布莱恩说他很大胆，我觉得这很酷。他希望角色尝试新事物。凯特说约翰是一位非常体贴的导演，在片场营造了很好的氛围。他确实在各个层面都做了功课。他非常认真地对待他的工作，但并不把自己当回事。就像他并不把自己当回事一样。那就是约翰。然后克里德说，哪个是约翰？天哪，克里德。克里德带着那个梗。太完美了。好吧。快速
fact number two, I'll have you know this was not John's directorial debut. What was? So this might have been the thing that inspired him to keep directing, but it was not his debut. He had written, produced and directed the film, Breathe, interviews with hideous men based on the short story collection by David Foster Wallace. I remember this from the time we did the pilot. John loved this book. And I guess he purchased the rights to the book with his first paycheck from the office. He had always wanted to adapt it. He's so smart like that. I know he's such a forward thinker. He is. Originally, he was just going to write and produce the film. Did you know John majored in screenwriting
事实二，我得让你知道这不是约翰的导演处女作。那是什么？所以这可能是激励他继续执导的事情，但这不是他的处女作。他编写、制作并执导了电影《男人之苦》，改编自大卫·福斯特·华莱士的短篇小说集。我记得我们拍试播集时就有这件事。约翰喜欢这本书。我想他用《办公室》的第一张薪水支票买下了这本书的版权。他一直想改编它。他就是那么聪明。我知道他是个很有远见的人。他是。最初，他只是打算编写和制作这部电影。你知道约翰在布朗大学主修编剧吗
at Brown University? I didn't know that. No. Yeah. So he majored in screenwriting, not acting. Writing was really his first love. So anyway, he had the rights, but he couldn't find a director. And I guess it was Rainn Wilson who said to him on set one day, why don't you just direct it yourself? That sounds like rain too. Rainn is very much the person that's like, why don't you just do it? You're like, Oh, okay. Yeah. So I guess Rainn Wilson kind of kickstarted John's directing career. The next thing he directed was this episode of the office. Then he directed two more episodes of the office. So three total. Then when the office was over, he directed a movie called The Haulers. And of course, A Quiet Place,
？我不知道。不。是的，所以他主修编剧，而不是表演。写作确实是他的初恋。总之，他有了版权，但他找不到导演。我想是雷恩·威尔逊在片场有一天对他说，你为什么不自己执导呢？那听起来也很像雷恩。雷恩确实是那种会说，你为什么不直接做呢？你就像，哦，好吧。是的。所以我想雷恩·威尔逊算是开启了约翰的导演生涯。他执导的下一部作品就是这一集《办公室》。然后他又执导了两集《办公室》。所以总共三集。然后当《办公室》结束后，他执导了一部名为《霍勒一家》的电影。当然，还有《寂静之地》，
which I watched on the plane. Oh, was I crazy? Oh, lady. John, did you yell out? Yes. I was like, I'm sure people thought I was crazy. Oh my gosh. Well, you know, his next directorial project is a film called If and he's reuniting with Steve Carell. Steve's going to be in it. Oh my gosh. We have to go see that together. Let's do it. So one more thing I want to point out before we move on to Fast Facts number three, because Fast Facts number three is all Angela. Oh no. So I'm squeezing a little extra information into my Fast Facts too. Squeeze it. Which is that we need to point out what a very big deal it was for John to direct this particular episode because he had to establish two new major characters in the
我在飞机上看了。哦，我疯了吗？哦，女士。约翰，你大叫了吗？是的。我当时想，我肯定人们觉得我疯了。天哪。好吧，你知道，他的下一个导演项目是一部名为《神秘友友》的电影，他将与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔重聚。史蒂夫会出演。天哪。我们必须一起去看。我们去吧。所以在我们进入快速事实三之前，我还要指出一件事，因为快速事实三全是安吉拉的。哦，不。所以我把一些额外的信息也塞进了我的快速事实里。塞进去吧。那就是我们需要指出约翰执导这一集是多么重要，因为他必须在剧中建立两个新的主要角色。
show. Kathy Bates as Joe Bennett and Zach Woods as Gabe Lewis. And he directed Christian Slater. So this was not just a regular episode of the office. That's right. He had to do the whole Saber video. Oh my gosh. I didn't even think about that. He had to start a whole new company. He had to like establish Saber. That's a big episode to make your directorial debut, my lord. Well, John talked a little bit about it. Here we go. Introducing Kathy Bates, which was so mind blowing. The Kathy Bates was not only on our show, but I was her first experience as a director. And for that, I will always be apologetic to her. But I remember introducing that character and knowing that, I don't know, feeling a
凯西·贝茨饰演乔·贝内特，扎克·伍兹饰演盖博·刘易斯。他还执导了克里斯蒂安·史莱特。所以这不仅仅是《办公室》的普通一集。没错。他必须完成整个Sabre视频。天哪。我甚至没想过那个。他必须开创一家全新的公司。他必须建立Sabre。作为导演处女作，这可是一集大制作，我的天。好吧，约翰谈到了一点。我们开始吧。介绍凯西·贝茨，这太令人震惊了。凯西·贝茨不仅出现在我们的剧集中，而且我是她作为导演的第一次经历。对此，我将永远向她道歉。但我记得介绍那个角色，并且知道，我不知道，感觉到一种
big responsibility that that character was going to be a big part of the show. And bringing along with her was Zach Woods, who I remember from the moment we shot his first stuff, the whole water bottle storyline. He was just so unbelievably funny. He was so reserved in this brand new instrument that we had to play with on the show, a totally different character than anybody else. And yet whenever he spoke, you couldn't take your eyes off of him. He was always so, so funny. And I just remember with the big story changes that were happening in the show, I was so nervous to be the one to introduce those two characters. And then in the end, I don't know, feel somewhat honored to have been to have been a part of
巨大的责任感，那个角色将成为剧集的重要组成部分。随之而来的是扎克·伍兹，我记得从我们拍摄他的第一场戏开始，整个水瓶的故事线。他简直太不可思议地搞笑了。他在这个我们必须在剧中使用的全新乐器中表现得如此矜持，一个与其他人完全不同的角色。然而每当他说话时，你就无法将目光从他身上移开。他总是那么那么有趣。我只记得随着剧中发生的大故事变化，我非常紧张成为介绍这两个角色的人。最后，我不知道，感到作为其中的一部分而感到荣幸。
it. I think those guys were lucky to have John as a director. He's so personable. He puts you so at ease. I mean, listen, all of our directors have a place in my heart. They're all great. But John really does have a gift at like walking into a room and just putting everyone like out of their heads. Do you know what I mean? He's a good connector. He is good at connecting. Yeah, instantly. All right, Angela. It's you. It's fast fact three. What do you got for me? Okay, here you go. Fast fact number three is courtesy of Joya Balfour. Oh, who as you guys know worked for NBC digital. She shared with us that NBC did an entire website for Sabre. The site featured a bio on CEO Joe Bennett, the full Christian
我认为那些家伙很幸运能有约翰作为导演。他太随和了。他让你感到非常自在。我的意思是，听着，我们所有的导演在我心中都有一席之地。他们都很棒。但约翰确实有一种天赋，走进一个房间就能让每个人放松下来。你知道我的意思吗？他是一个很好的连接者。他很擅长连接。是的，瞬间。好吧，安吉拉。轮到你了。这是快速事实三。你有什么要告诉我的？好吧，给你。快速事实三由乔亚·巴尔福提供。哦，正如你们所知，她为NBC数字部门工作。她与我们分享说，NBC为Sabre制作了一个完整的网站。该网站以首席执行官乔·贝内特的人物简介、完整的克里斯蒂安·
Slater video, a section with a company overview, plus it featured all of Sabre's, oh my God, I'm doing it. Plus it featured all of Sabre's printer products, a Q&A with Kelly Kapoor in an article titled Printin' All Colors. And my favorite section was an employee blog by Scranton accountant Oscar Martinez. And the blog was titled There's No Accounting for Taste. What? Yeah. And here were a few of his blogs he posted. One was titled Winter Woe. The next one was titled Music Makes the People Come Together and annoys me at the office. Oh my gosh. Lastly, he wrote a blog called A Different Voice. Joya found an archive of the website. The video's not on it, but some of the different elements are. I'll
史莱特视频、一个包含公司概况的部分为特色，此外它还展示了所有Sabre的，哦天哪，我在做了。此外它还展示了所有Sabre的打印机产品、凯莉·卡普尔的问答，以及一篇题为《彩色打印》的文章。我最喜欢的部分是斯克兰顿会计师奥斯卡·马丁内斯写的员工博客。博客标题是《众口难调》。什么？是的。以下是他发布的一些博客。一个是《冬日之忧》。下一个是《音乐让人们聚在一起，却在办公室里让我烦恼》。天哪。最后，他写了一篇名为《不同的声音》的博客。乔亚找到了该网站的存档。视频不在上面，但一些不同的元素还在。我会
share in stories. It is hilarious. Oh my gosh. I know. I didn't know any of that stuff. I feel like NBC.com, like we've talked about it. They were just sort of ahead of the curve. Yeah. Another thing happening online at this time was a lot of people were very sad to see David Wallace go. And a save Wallace campaign started online. There was even a contest on OfficeTally.com where you could make a save Wallace icon. And a bunch of the icons are still up there. I'll put a few in stories. No way. Wow. But yeah, this was a huge episode. We're finally seeing Saber. So NBC really went all out. They were clearly excited about their Thursday night lineup this week because you know our favorite Announcery guy. Uh-huh.
在故事里分享。这太搞笑了。天哪。我知道。我不知道那些东西。我觉得NBC.com，就像我们谈论过的那样。他们只是有点走在时代前沿。是的。当时网上发生的另一件事是很多人看到大卫·华莱士离开感到非常难过。网上发起了一场“拯救华莱士”运动。OfficeTally.com上甚至举办了一场比赛，你可以制作一个“拯救华莱士”的图标。很多图标还在那里。我会放几个在故事里。不会吧。哇。但确实，这是一集巨大的剧集。我们终于看到了Sabre。所以NBC真的全力以赴了。他们显然对本周的周四晚间阵容感到兴奋，因为你知道我们最喜欢的播音员。嗯哼。
He came back and they did a trailer. Here's the trailer that ran the week Saber aired. Thursday, we're putting the word out. Comedy's new on NBC. Check your e-mail. I'm Mark U.S. Spam. Who the hell's Pam? With new community in Parks and Rec. We're quite happy everybody is. While the office has been taken over by Kathy Bates and Christian Slater. Have you ever tasted a rainbow? You're probably wondering, what's going on? Well, you're not alone. And here's what to expect when Jen Hooks is on 30 Rock. This show will have laughter. Tears. It's caused by jacuzzi water. Yep. The comedy is new this Thursday on NBC. Yep. The comedy is new. I want John to do an impression of that guy. Yeah, right. Me too. Oh, well, that
他回来了，他们做了一个预告片。这是Sabre播出那周的预告片。周四，我们要发布消息了。NBC的新喜剧。检查你的电子邮件。我是马克·U.S.垃圾邮件。谁是帕姆？随着《废柴联盟》和《公园与游憩》。我们很高兴每个人都是。而《办公室》已经被凯西·贝茨和克里斯蒂安·史莱特接管了。你尝过彩虹的味道吗？你可能在想，发生了什么？好吧，你并不孤单。这就是当珍·霍克斯出现在《我为喜剧狂》时可以期待的内容。这部剧会有笑声。泪水。这是由按摩浴缸的水引起的。是的。喜剧就在本周四在NBC播出。是的。喜剧是新的。我希望约翰能模仿那个家伙。是的，没错。我也是。哦，好吧，那
was wonderful, Angela. Oh, you're welcome. You know, I've said before, I think you could always do FastFact3 if you wanna. Okay. Happy to give it away. Happy to give away something you created for yourself. Something I didn't think about on episode one was that there would be, let's see, 600 FastFacts that I'd have to come up with. But by episode 115, it's not as easy as it used to be. I am here for you anytime you need a FastFact assist. Thank you, lady. You're welcome. Let's take a break and then we'll be back to break down Sabre. Let's see how Michael opens a box, you guys. All right. This episode starts with Michael, who is so excited because they have received
太棒了，安吉拉。哦，不客气。你知道，我以前说过，如果你想的话，我觉得你总是可以做快速事实三。好吧。很高兴把它让出来。很高兴让出你自己创造的东西。我在第一集时没想过的是，会有，让我们看看，600个我必须想出来的快速事实。但到了第115集，它不像以前那么容易了。我随时在这里为你提供快速事实协助。谢谢你，女士。不客气。让我们休息一下，然后回来剖析Sabre。让我们看看迈克尔是怎么拆盒子的，伙计们。好吧。这一集以迈克尔开始，他非常兴奋，因为他们收到了
a huge large box from Sabre, their new owners. Uh-huh. And he asked Aaron to scissor him. Right. Which means to, I guess, toss him scissors from across the room. Throw scissors at him. Pam is the only one that clocks this as disturbing. Yes. We had two fan questions that I loved. The first is from Sessia Z in London, Ontario, Canada, who said, when Michael says that the box is from Sabre to Sabre, us. Michael says the us as if he's referring to everyone in the office. But in reality, the us probably means United States. I think that's the funniest thing ever. I loved that. It didn't occur to me until I read this letter right that that's what he was doing. Our other bit of mail came from Haley H in Beaumont,
一个来自Sabre（他们的新东家）的巨大盒子。嗯哼。他让艾琳剪他。没错。这意味着，我想，从房间对面扔剪刀给他。向他扔剪刀。帕姆是唯一一个觉得这很令人不安的人。是的。我们有两个我喜欢的粉丝提问。第一个来自加拿大安大略省伦敦的Sessia Z，她说，当迈克尔说盒子是来自Sabre给Sabre，我们。迈克尔说“我们”好像是指办公室里的每个人。但实际上，“我们”可能指的是美国。我觉得这是有史以来最有趣的事情。我喜欢那个。直到我读到这封信，我才想到他是在那样做。我们的另一封邮件来自博蒙特的Haley H，
Alberta, Canada, and also many others, by the way, wrote in to say, how did you guys do the bit when Aaron throws the scissors to Michael? Are they fakey scissors? I hope so. Yes. They were fakey scissors. They were made by Phil Shea via the hand prop room. Randy Cordray confirmed that they were rubber, but they looked very real. I remember this about them. They did not open and close. They were permanently in the open position. Because they were rubber because they were rubber. Randy said that they added a special effects sound and post to make them sound like real scissors. So amazing. I kind of want to go to the hand prop room. What are they making over there? Can we do a factory tour of the
加拿大阿尔伯塔省，顺便说一句，还有许多其他人写信问，你们是怎么做艾琳扔剪刀给迈克尔的那一段的？那是假剪刀吗？我希望是。是的。那是假剪刀。它们是由菲尔·谢通过道具室制作的。兰迪·科德雷证实它们是橡胶做的，但看起来非常真实。我记得关于它们的这一点。它们不能打开和关闭。它们永久处于打开位置。因为它们是橡胶做的，因为它们是橡胶做的。兰迪说他们在后期添加了特效声音，让它们听起来像真正的剪刀。太神奇了。我有点想去道具室。他们在那里做什么？我们可以做一个工厂参观
hand prop room? I would love nothing more. How does that work? I don't know. You call up and say, I need fakey scissors in the open position. Where do you do it? How does this happen? I bet that's where Phil Shea had the teeny, tiny, real tennis racket made for my son's Halloween costume when he was a baby. We just have a lot of factory tours, and I can't wait for each one. Hand prop room. We're coming for you. Well, Michael is going to tear into this box with those rubber scissors. Yep. And there is a running joke in my family, lady, that I do it wrong when it comes to opening packages. Do you open it like Michael? I just get it open. I get it open. So that's a yes. So you know how like some packages
道具室吗？我再没有什么比这更想要的了。那是怎么运作的？我不知道。你打电话说，我需要处于打开位置的假剪刀。你在哪里做？这是怎么发生的？我敢打赌，菲尔·谢就是在那儿为我儿子婴儿时期的万圣节服装制作了那个微小的、真正的网球拍。我们只是有很多工厂参观，我迫不及待地想参加每一个。道具室。我们来了。好吧，迈克尔要用那些橡胶剪刀撕开这个盒子。没错。而且我家有一个持续的笑话，女士，那就是我在拆包裹时做得不对。你像迈克尔那样拆吗？我只是把它打开。我把它打开。所以那是肯定的。所以你知道有些包裹
come with like a little built in Ziploc-y thing? Yeah. And if you open it correctly, the Ziploc will work. Yeah. I never get it right. Okay. Like that's not going to happen. Or there will be a big thing that says peel here. I miss that every time. That's not going to happen. So if something's really like a disaster in the pantry, chances are I opened it. That's very funny. I think you know how I open a box. I mean, probably meticulously along the little perforated line. Well, yeah, because number one, what if I need to reuse it? You know, what if I don't like what's inside and I have to return it? I'm going to need that packaging. Oh, yeah. Or what if I do like what's inside? I'm going to want
自带那种内置的拉链式东西吗？是的。如果你正确打开它，拉链就能用。是的。我从来没弄对过。好吧，就像那不会发生一样。或者会有一个大东西写着“从这里撕开”。我每次都错过。那不会发生。所以如果储藏室里有什么东西真的是一场灾难，很有可能是我打开的。那太有趣了。我想你知道我是怎么拆盒子的。我的意思是，可能沿着那个小穿孔线一丝不苟地拆。好吧，是的，因为第一，如果我需要重复使用它怎么办？你知道，如果我不喜欢里面的东西，我必须退货怎么办？我需要那个包装。哦，是的。或者如果我喜欢里面的东西怎么办？我会想
to break that down and put it in the recycling. You know what I mean? I'll break it down. I mean, it's already broken down by the time I open it. Anyway, when I saw that scene, I was like, Josh, is that me? And he was like, uh, yeah. That's amazing. Yeah. Well, Michael's going to have a great talking head now where he explains that Dunder Mifflin was acquired by an electronics company that saw Bray stepped in and saved their butts at the 11th hour. I want to point out that during this talking head at 29 seconds, Chris Workman, who was our first assistant camera operator is the person who is putting up the saber sign underneath the Dunder Mifflin sign in the lobby. That's Chris. That's Chris. Oh, I love that. Well,
把它拆掉放进回收站。你知道我的意思吗？我会把它拆掉。我的意思是，在我打开它的时候它已经拆开了。总之，当我看到那个场景时，我说，乔什，那是我吗？他说，呃，是的。那太神奇了。是的。好吧，迈克尔现在要有一个很棒的谈话头，他解释说邓德·米夫林被一家电子公司收购了，Sabre介入并在最后一刻拯救了他们。我想指出，在这个谈话头期间，在29秒时，我们的第一助理摄像师克里斯·沃克曼正在大厅里把Sabre标志贴在邓德·米夫林标志下面。那是克里斯。那是克里斯。哦，我喜欢那个。好吧，
there was a candy bag talking head alternate. Oh, and it was a must shoot. So we shot this, but it wasn't used. And I just loved it so much. Here was the alt talking head for Michael. Dunder Mifflin was recently bought out by an electronics company named Sabre. Great things come from the South like chili and Wyoming. Well, now you can add another distinguished name to that list. Michael rodeo cowboy Garth Brooks Scott. Where is Wyoming? He thinks it's the South. It's not the South, but that's just so funny to me that he's like, great things come from the South like me and a rodeo and a cowboy and Garth Brooks shouting things out chili Wyoming. At 42 seconds, you see Michael taking everything out of the box.
有一个糖果袋谈话头的替代版本。哦，这是一个必须拍摄的镜头。所以我们拍了这个，但没用上。我太喜欢它了。这是迈克尔的替代谈话头。邓德·米夫林最近被一家名为Sabre的电子公司收购了。伟大的事物来自南方，比如辣椒和怀俄明州。好吧，现在你可以把另一个杰出的名字加到那个名单上了。迈克尔·牛仔竞技牛仔·加斯·布鲁克斯·斯科特。怀俄明州在哪里？他认为那是南方。那不是南方，但这对我来说太搞笑了，他就像，伟大的事物来自南方，比如我和牛仔竞技和牛仔和加斯·布鲁克斯大喊大叫辣椒怀俄明州。在42秒时，你看到迈克尔把所有东西从盒子里拿出来。
There is the saber graphics on each product that was of course created by our graphics designer, Henry saying Phil Shea once again used the hand prop room to fabricate the individual product boxes that everything came in. I'm going to stock this place. I'm going to the hand prop room. I know, I know. You know what, Ange, I recently had to do props for my son's fourth grade play. Jenna, you were so excited about it. You left me several messages. You were giddy because it was a play that was set during the gold rush. It was so cool. The class writes the play themselves based on a topic they're learning in class. They were learning about hydraulic mining and government regulations during the gold rush. So that's
每个产品上都有Sabre图形，那当然是由我们的图形设计师亨利创建的，菲尔·谢再次使用道具室来制造所有东西装在里面的独立产品盒。我要把这个地方填满。我要去道具室。我知道，我知道。你知道吗，安吉，我最近不得不为我儿子的四年级戏剧做道具。珍娜，你对此太兴奋了。你给我留了几条信息。你很兴奋，因为那是一部以淘金热为背景的戏剧。太酷了。班级根据他们在课堂上学习的主题自己编写剧本。他们正在学习淘金热期间的水力采矿和政府法规。所以这就是
what they wrote their play about. And I was on the props team and they needed an old timey camera and an old timey typewriter and an old timey cash register. Guess who I called? Phil Shea. Phil Shea. Phil was like, I know where to send you. You need to go to this place called history for hire. And they have all old timey stuff, like an old timey telephone, an old timey like box of cereal, whatever you need in there. And you like kind of rent it like a library, like how you used to check out a book. Yes. So I go into this place. It's a huge warehouse. It's actually very close to where we shot our show over on Satakoy. I was like, oh my God, this is the greatest museum. I spent like a half hour there just
他们编写剧本的内容。我是道具组的，他们需要一个老式相机、一个老式打字机和一个老式收银机。猜猜我给谁打了电话？菲尔·谢。菲尔·谢。菲尔说，我知道把你送到哪里。你需要去这个叫“历史租赁”的地方。他们有所有老式的东西，比如老式电话、老式麦片盒，任何你需要的东西都在那里。你就像租书一样租它，就像你过去借书一样。是的。所以我走进这个地方。这是一个巨大的仓库。它实际上离我们拍摄节目的地方很近，在萨塔科伊。我说，哦天哪，这是最伟大的博物馆。我在那里花了半小时只是
like walking around. It was amazing. Am I going to go into like props? Maybe. I don't know. Does Phil need an assistant, an intern, something? Oh my gosh. A protégé. You know what I would love? I would love to show up to a set and you walk out with a tray of different types of like mallard ducks for me to use in my scene. I'm like, Jenna, I'm working with Phil today. I'm working with Phil. We've got a lot of props. And I'm going to use a silver tray because that's what. That's how you do it. Yeah. How Phil taught me. Well, this box contains a new printer for accounting, a fax machine for sales, and the thing Michael is most excited about, a scanner. Yes. He immediately starts scanning weird things like
四处走走。太神奇了。我会进入道具行业吗？也许吧。我不知道。菲尔需要助手、实习生什么的吗？天哪。门徒。你知道我想要什么吗？我想要出现在片场，你端着一盘不同类型的绿头鸭让我用在我的场景里。我说，珍娜，我今天和菲尔一起工作。我和菲尔一起工作。我们有很多道具。而且我会用一个银盘子，因为那是。那是你怎么做的。是的。菲尔教我的。好吧，这个盒子包含了一台新的会计打印机、一台销售传真机，以及迈克尔最兴奋的东西，一台扫描仪。是的。他立刻开始扫描奇怪的东西，就像
a child would. You know, Jenna, I just got so tickled when I saw Michael like playing with the scanner because in my grandmother's early nineties, that's what she wanted for Christmas one year. And we got her a scanner and she was so delighted by it. She had all of these like newspaper clippings and anything that any of her grandkids ever accomplished or were written up about. She had saved them all and she just started scanning them. She was just archiving. She was archiving in her nineties. Bless her heart. I know. I know. Well, Michael is scanning his little hamster toy. Yeah. Not the same. Not the same. And that's when Erin's like, yeah, this box was for a Gabe. It said set aside for Gabe. Yeah.
一个孩子会做的那样。你知道，珍娜，当我看到迈克尔像玩扫描仪一样玩时，我感到非常高兴，因为在我祖母九十多岁时，那是她一年圣诞节想要的。我们给她买了一台扫描仪，她对此感到非常高兴。她有所有这些剪报，以及她的孙子孙女们取得的任何成就或被报道过的事情。她把它们都保存了下来，她只是开始扫描它们。她在九十多岁时还在存档。保佑她的心。我知道。我知道。好吧，迈克尔正在扫描他的小仓鼠玩具。是的。不一样。不一样。就在那时艾琳说，是的，这个盒子是给盖博的。上面写着留给盖博。是的。
So now they have to get all of the things and they have to put it all back into the box and seal it up. I loved this scene. I love this scene so much. You and I were recently asked in an interview what we are loving about this rewatch. And I am loving these big ensemble scenes where we all have to do one ridiculous task together. Oh my gosh. Pam and Oscar are trying to put the stuff in the box with everybody weighing in. Amazing. Amazing. By the way, I want to say at two minutes, 14 seconds in the background on the wall, the watercolor is back. Finally. Finally. Nine episodes later. Wow. It's back and it will be there. Yay. Hoping a frame on the wall. On the wall. So now we have the opening credits of this
所以现在他们必须把所有东西拿出来，放回盒子里并密封起来。我喜欢这个场景。我太喜欢这个场景了。你和我最近在一次采访中被问到我们喜欢这次重温的什么。我喜欢这些大型群戏，我们所有人必须一起完成一个荒谬的任务。天哪。帕姆和奥斯卡试图把东西放进盒子里，每个人都在发表意见。太棒了。太棒了。顺便说一句，我想说在2分14秒时，背景墙上的水彩画回来了。终于。终于。九集之后。哇。它回来了，它会一直待在那里。耶。希望墙上有一个框。在墙上。所以现在我们有了这个
show and I don't know if you notice, but we've got a Mr. Ed Helms in there now. Yes. We get a quick shot of him. Ryan is no longer holding up his bag of basketball stuff. Instead, we've got Ed Helms at the top. His movie was a very, very big success. Yes. He moved right into those opening credits. He sure did. Well, everyone is very excited. They're waiting for Gabe's arrival and Pam's like, Michael, what do you want us to do? And he's like, do I have to explain everything? And she's like, yes, because usually we're not on the same page. And then they just all start applauding. And she's like, I'm saying she, it was me. I know. Pam is like, I guess this is what we're doing. We're applauding. Yeah. Okay.
节目的片头，我不知道你有没有注意到，我们现在有艾德·赫尔姆斯先生在里面了。是的。我们得到了他的一张快照。瑞安不再举着他的篮球包了。相反，我们在顶部有艾德·赫尔姆斯。他的电影非常非常成功。是的。他直接进入了那些片头。他确实做到了。好吧，每个人都很兴奋。他们正在等待盖博的到来，帕姆说，迈克尔，你想要我们做什么？他说，我必须解释一切吗？她说，是的，因为通常我们不在同一个频道上。然后他们就开始鼓掌。她说，我说她，那是我。我知道。帕姆就像，我想这就是我们要做的。我们在鼓掌。是的。好吧。
Well guys, new character alert. Zach Woods played Gabe Lewis. Zach Woods was born in Trenton, New Jersey and is a graduate of NYU. Is this your bio voice? It is. It will now read a bio. I have a new bio voice. Oh, okay. At age 16, he began performing improv at Upright Citizens Brigade. Doesn't it sound like you could be watching like a montage of his life over this narration? Sort of. Okay. Close your eyes. Visualize. Okay. I'm gonna close my eyes. He has even taught improv at UCB, Columbia and Duke Universities as well as at Lincoln Center. In addition to his role on the office, Zach is well known for his roles on such shows as Veep, The Good Wife and Silicon Valley. Fan question from Kyle
好吧伙计们，新角色警报。扎克·伍兹饰演盖博·刘易斯。扎克·伍兹出生于新泽西州特伦顿，是纽约大学的毕业生。这是你的简介声音吗？是的。它现在将阅读简介。我有一个新的简介声音。哦，好吧。16岁时，他开始在“正直公民旅”表演即兴表演。这听起来不像是在这段叙述中观看他的人生蒙太奇吗？有点。好吧。闭上眼睛。想象一下。好吧。我要闭上眼睛。他甚至在UCB、哥伦比亚大学和杜克大学以及林肯中心教授即兴表演。除了在《办公室》中的角色外，扎克还以他在《副总统》、《傲骨贤妻》和《硅谷》等剧集中的角色而闻名。粉丝提问来自凯尔
T. in Houston, Texas. Do y'all have a favorite story about working with Zach Woods? Kyle? Every story about working with Zach Woods is my favorite. He is one of my favorite people professionally, personally. He is a gem of a human being. Kyle, I'm gonna tell you right now, he is straight up good people. He is good people and he's so flippin' funny. So funny. He's so funny and I love improv. You know, that's my background and I would lose myself in a scene because I would watch him go off script at the right moment. It was never selfish. It was like exactly if we needed something, he was just perfection. I was like beyond impressed with him. He has a command of language in improv that is like
T.，德克萨斯州休斯顿。你们有关于和扎克·伍兹一起工作的最喜欢的故事吗？凯尔？关于和扎克·伍兹一起工作的每一个故事都是我最喜欢的。他在专业上、个人上都是我最喜欢的人之一。他是一个宝石般的人。凯尔，我现在就告诉你，他绝对是个好人。他是好人，而且他太搞笑了。太有趣了。他太有趣了，我喜欢即兴表演。你知道，那是我的背景，我会迷失在场景中，因为我会看着他在正确的时刻脱稿。这从来不是自私的。就像如果我们需要什么，他就是完美。我对他印象深刻。他在即兴表演中对语言的掌控力就像
otherworldly. There are some great bloopers of him just talking and he doesn't stop talking, but he's not even saying jokes. He's just like, it's so funny and people are dying. We couldn't get through scenes. Well, he never went for the joke. That's what I mean that he was patient and not selfish. He was never about the joke. Anyway, we could go on and on. He was wonderful. Kyle, we loved him. We loved him. You know, there's a lot in the shooting draft that didn't make it in the script and there is a scene that starts an accounting runner right here that I wanted to share with you guys because it's gonna reveal a little bit of Oscar's backstory. Really? Yes. Okay. Here's a hint. It involves
超凡脱俗。有一些很棒的他的花絮，他只是在说话，他甚至没有停下来，但他甚至没有讲笑话。他只是，这太搞笑了，人们都笑死了。我们无法完成场景。好吧，他从不为了笑话而笑话。这就是我的意思，他很有耐心，不自私。他从来不是为了笑话。总之，我们可以继续说下去。他太棒了。凯尔，我们爱他。我们爱他。你知道，拍摄草稿里有很多没进剧本的内容，这里有一个以会计跑腿开始的场景，我想和你们分享，因为它会揭示一点奥斯卡的背景故事。真的吗？是的。好吧。这是一个提示。它涉及
advanced refrigeration. What? I know, right? Got you guessing now. In the script, Gabe is on his way up, right? Yep. And in accounting, Angela quickly swipes a big stack from Kevin's desk into the trash. Oh. Kevin says, hey, what are you doing? Angela says, this is accounting. It's not your home, your car or your stomach. Hmm. Kevin says, jokes on you because that was work stuff in there. Angela says, it was fake work. I gave all the real work to Oscar today, to which Kevin goes, hey, and Oscar goes again. Lady, I remember reading this at the table read and it was so funny, this idea that Angela gives Kevin fakey work. Yes. Well, this runner continues throughout the episode. There's two more beats to it. I'll
高级制冷。什么？我知道，对吧？让你猜到了吧。在剧本中，盖博正在上来，对吧？没错。在会计部，安吉拉迅速把凯文桌上的一大堆东西扫进垃圾桶。哦。凯文说，嘿，你在做什么？安吉拉说，这是会计部。这不是你的家、你的车或你的胃。嗯。凯文说，笑话在你身上，因为里面有工作的东西。安吉拉说，那是假工作。我今天把所有真正的工作都给了奥斯卡，凯文说，嘿，奥斯卡说，又来了。女士，我记得在剧本朗读会上读到这个，这太搞笑了，安吉拉给凯文假工作的想法。是的。好吧，这个跑腿在整集中持续。还有两个节拍。我会
share it when it happens. Oh my gosh, I totally remember that. Well, listen, once Gabe does come into the office, he is presented with a platter of Scranton hot dogs. My favorite part of this beat was watching Rain as Dwight try to figure out where to set the hot dogs down. And there was no place to set them down. We got a fan question from Sophia in Maryland about that. Sophia wanted to know, when Dwight awkwardly places the tray of hot dogs on the floor in front of Gabe, was this scripted or improvised? Sophia, that was scripted. You were watching just Rain Wilson do some brilliant execution of a scripted moment. I became curious about this pride that Dwight had over the fact that these were Scranton
在它发生时分享。天哪，我完全记得那个。好吧，听着，一旦盖博来到办公室，他就收到了一盘斯克兰顿热狗。我最喜欢这个节拍的部分是看着雷恩饰演的德怀特试图弄清楚把热狗放在哪里。没有地方可以放它们。我们收到了马里兰州索菲亚关于那个的粉丝提问。索菲亚想知道，当德怀特尴尬地把那盘热狗放在盖博面前的地板上时，这是剧本写的还是即兴的？索菲亚，那是剧本写的。你只是在看雷恩·威尔逊对剧本时刻的精彩执行。我对德怀特因为这些是斯克兰顿
hot dogs. I wondered, is there something that I don't know about? Yeah, is there a Scranton hot dog and hot dogs? Well, according to Pennsylvania eats, they have an article called the Pennsylvania hot dog bucket list. You can just travel through Pennsylvania eating hot dogs. And here is what it said. For an old school hot dog experience in Scranton, look no further than Coney Island lunch where it's all about Texas weaners, which are a bit different than your standard hot dog. Using a 93 year old recipe, Coney Island lunch makes its hot dogs with a Berks all beef weiner on a national bakery roll topped with doosal dwarf mustard, fresh diced onions and its famous chili sauce, which is also available for sale by the pint or quart.
热狗而产生的自豪感感到好奇。我想知道，有什么我不知道的事情吗？是的，有斯克兰顿热狗和热狗吗？好吧，根据宾夕法尼亚州饮食，他们有一篇文章叫《宾夕法尼亚热狗愿望清单》。你可以穿过宾夕法尼亚州吃热狗。这就是它说的。对于斯克兰顿的老派热狗体验，看看康尼岛午餐就知道了，那里全是德州香肠，这与你的标准热狗有点不同。使用93年的配方，康尼岛午餐用伯克斯全牛肉香肠在国家面包店的面包上制作热狗，上面撒上杜萨尔矮芥末、新鲜切碎的洋葱和著名的辣椒酱，也可以按品脱或夸脱出售。
Though not quite traditional, you can also top yours with cheddar cheese sauce, sweet relish and sauerkraut. Beloved in the region, this lunch counters Texas weiner was named third best in the USA by Fox News, and it was also ranked on the Daily Meals list of the 35 best hot dogs in America. So I guess Scranton is making the dogs. So this was true. True. As everyone's applauding for Gabe, Gabe applauds right back and says, and to you. Amazing. Amazing moment. And Michael says, you know, we're so excited to meet you. We've even prepared a song for you. Yes. To which Gabe says, Oh, I'm going to record it and put it on the Saber website. And immediately
虽然不太传统，但你也可以在上面加切达干酪酱、甜味调味酱和酸菜。这款午餐柜台的德州热狗在该地区很受欢迎，被福克斯新闻评为全美第三，还登上了《每日餐点》评选的美国35款最佳热狗榜单。所以我猜斯克兰顿是在做热狗。所以这是真的。真的。当大家为盖博鼓掌时，盖博也回敬大家说，也谢谢你们。太棒了。精彩的时刻。迈克尔说，你知道，我们很高兴见到你。我们甚至为你准备了一首歌。是的。盖博说，哦，我要把它录下来放到赛博的网站上。然后立刻
Michael looks at everyone and goes, Saber, Saber, and everyone's like, Oh, Saber, Saber. Well, it's not going to be enough time for Andy and Aaron to adjust their song that they've planned. It is amazing, this song. It is a song parody to the tune of Party in the USA by Miley Cyrus. I thought we should listen to it. Hopped off the train in Scranton, P.A., another cloudy gray afternoon. Jumped in the cab, he walked for the first time, took a ride, and you see the electric city sign. This is going to be a good day. But under Miffin and Saber. Saber. Saber. Under Miffin and Saber. So yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
迈克尔看着大家说，赛博，赛博，大家都说，哦，赛博，赛博。好吧，安迪和亚伦没有足够的时间来调整他们计划好的歌曲。这首歌太棒了。这是一首改编自麦莉·赛勒斯的《美国派对》的歌曲。我想我们应该听听。跳下斯克兰顿的火车，又是一个阴沉的灰色下午。跳进出租车，他第一次走路，搭了便车，你看到了电力之城的标志。这会是美好的一天。但在米芬和赛博之下。赛博。赛博。在米芬和赛博之下。所以，是的，是的，是的，是的。
Under Miffin is a part of Saber. So yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Under Miffin is a part of Saber. Oh my God, it makes me laugh so hard. They're really good, too. I know they are. We had a fan question from Rachel S. in Benton, Arkansas. Who wrote the Saber song to the tune Party in the USA? Rachel, it was scripted by our writers Warren Lieberstein and Hal Steads Sullivan. Remember, those are the guys who wrote Koi Pond. Now, Jen Salata shared that they also had to write lyrics to two other songs because they didn't know what song was eventually going to get cleared. So I guess they wrote lyrics to I Got a Feeling by Black Eyed Peas and Surfing in the USA by The Beach
米芬是赛博的一部分。所以，是的，是的，是的，是的。米芬是赛博的一部分。天哪，这让我笑得好厉害。他们唱得也很好。我知道他们唱得好。我们收到了来自阿肯色州本顿市瑞秋·S的粉丝提问。是谁把《美国派对》改编成了赛博之歌？瑞秋，这是我们的编剧沃伦·利伯斯坦和哈尔·斯特兹·沙利文写的。记住，就是写《锦鲤池》的那几个人。现在，珍·萨拉塔分享说，他们还必须为另外两首歌写歌词，因为他们不知道最终哪首歌会被批准。所以我猜他们为黑眼豆豆的《我感觉到了》和海滩男孩的《在美国冲浪》写了歌词
Boys, but they did eventually get the rights to Party in the USA. It's something called Song Parody Rights and it costs $23,000. Well, I texted Warren about this and I was like, how did you guys get assigned to writing this? And he said, Hal Stead and I both sang acapella in college and we were a little nerdy about it. This was before Pitch Perfect made acapella nerdy cool. So the writers kind of knew us as that. We always jumped at the chance to write lyrics for anything. It was just fun for us. Lady, both your ex-husband and your current husband sang acapella in college. I know.
男孩们，但他们最终还是获得了《美国派对》的版权。这叫歌曲改编权，花费了23000美元。好吧，我给沃伦发了短信，问他是怎么被分配写这个的？他说，哈尔·斯特兹和我在大学里都唱过阿卡贝拉，我们对此有点书呆子气。这还是在《完美音调》让阿卡贝拉变得酷起来之前。所以编剧们有点把我们当成那样的人。我们总是抓住机会为任何东西写歌词。这对我们来说只是好玩。女士，你的前夫和现任丈夫在大学里都唱过阿卡贝拉。我知道。
There is a thread to follow there. I know. Although when I was in college, I didn't know anyone that did acapella. Acapella. What? Acapella. Hello, lady. Thanks to our writer's assistant, Rob Burnett, I was able to get a hold of the Surfing in the USA version of the Sabre song. And Cassie had her friend, Yaki Margolese, who is an actor, musician and Big Beach Boys fan, record it for us. Here it is.
这中间有一条线索。我知道。虽然我在大学时，不认识任何唱阿卡贝拉的人。阿卡贝拉。什么？阿卡贝拉。你好，女士。多亏了我们的编剧助理罗布·伯内特，我才拿到了《在美国冲浪》版本的赛博之歌。凯西让她的朋友亚基·马戈利斯（一位演员、音乐家和海滩男孩的超级粉丝）为我们录制了它。就在这里。
We'd like to welcome our new boss from Tallahassee Way. Thanks for making the long trip to Tundra Mifflin P.A. Have a coffee and dinner. Take off your coat and stay. Over there that's the famous she's working for Sabre. Back there in the animes, Kelly and Ryan play. Kevin Oscar and Angela. And Numbel of A. And everyone on the 16. Creamer, Edith and Taupe. Are happy Happy to be working, working for Sabrae. We're happy to be working, working for Sabrae. Happy to be working, working for Sabrae. Happy to be working, working for Sabrae.
我们想欢迎来自塔拉哈西的新老板。感谢你长途跋涉来到米芬宾夕法尼亚州。喝杯咖啡，吃顿晚餐。脱下外套留下来。那边那位著名的女士正在为赛博工作。在那边，凯利和瑞安在玩。凯文、奥斯卡和安吉拉。还有16号的努贝尔。每个人都在16号。克里默、伊迪丝和陶佩。很高兴，很高兴能工作，为赛博工作。我们很高兴能工作，为赛博工作。很高兴能工作，为赛博工作。很高兴能工作，为赛博工作。
I mean, that is an amazing Brian Wilson impression. It's so good. So. It's so stinking good. And Warren and Halstead had to write all those lyrics for that. I know. And talk about Small World. I know, Yaki.
我的意思是，那是一个令人惊叹的布莱恩·威尔逊模仿秀。太棒了。所以。太棒了。沃伦和哈尔·斯特兹不得不为那首歌写了所有的歌词。我知道。谈谈小世界。我知道，亚基。
I know. So, he officiates bar and bat mitzvahs, and he officiated a bat mitzvah that you were at in Ojai, like, very recently. Three weeks ago. That's crazy. He's wonderful. That was so great. Yaki, thank you.
我知道。所以，他主持成人礼，他最近在欧海主持了一场你参加的成人礼。三周前。太疯狂了。他很棒。那太棒了。亚基，谢谢你。
Well, Jim is being just adorable new dad. He's map quested directions, even though it's just a few minutes away, to their appointment to look at a daycare. Pam and Jim are going to tour daycares. Can I say something? What? In this scene? Yes.
好吧，吉姆表现得像个可爱的准爸爸。他查了地图导航，尽管离他们预约看日托中心的地方只有几分钟的路程。帕姆和吉姆要去参观日托中心。我能说点什么吗？什么？在这一幕里？是的。
Jim is being adorable. But at five minutes and nine seconds, that fuzzy, eyes half closed, frizzy haired photo of Pam is very clearly on Jim's desk. What is that? What is that? I don't know. It is so bizarre to me that this is a photo that has made its way into a frame ever, and is so prominently on Jim's desk.
吉姆表现得很可爱。但在5分09秒时，那张帕姆眼睛半闭、头发蓬松的照片非常清晰地放在吉姆的桌子上。那是什么？那是什么？我不知道。对我来说，这张照片竟然被装进相框，还如此显眼地放在吉姆的桌子上，真是太奇怪了。
Maybe that's the young gal he fell in love with. That frizzy hair. She can't open her eyes all the way? No. No. She's constantly mid-blink? My sister, Billy, rarely has her eyes open in any photo. I don't know.
也许那是他爱上的那个年轻女孩。那蓬松的头发。她不能完全睁开眼睛吗？不。不。她总是处于眨眼状态？我妹妹比利，在任何照片里都很少睁开眼睛。我不知道。
I'll let it go, but it's there. Pam and Jim have a talking head where they explain that they have found a very highly rated local daycare it's very hard to get into. So they have to go in for an interview. Yeah. And I think Jim has his first dad pun where he says, if not, there's always the army, the infantry. He's so ready to be a dad.
我先放过它，但它就在那里。帕姆和吉姆有一个谈话环节，他们解释说他们找到了一家评价很高的当地日托中心，很难进去。所以他们必须去面试。是的。我想吉姆有了他第一个爸爸笑话，他说，如果不成，还有军队，步兵。他已经准备好当爸爸了。
Dad pun. Way to go. Well, there was an alt-Jim Pam talking head that was in the shooting draft. It was a must shoot. I have to read it to you. He made me laugh. Okay. Pam says, we found a great local daycare, but it's really hard to get into.
爸爸笑话。干得好。好吧，拍摄草稿里有一个吉姆和帕姆的备选谈话环节。这是一个必须拍摄的片段。我得读给你听。他让我笑了。好的。帕姆说，我们找到了一家很棒的当地日托中心，但真的很难进去。
Jim says, ideally we would have called the moment we conceived. Pam says, but usually you fall right asleep. Whoa. Okay. Some TMI there. Yeah. About Jim and Pam. I know.
吉姆说，理想情况下，我们应该在受孕的那一刻就打电话。帕姆说，但通常你马上就睡着了。哇。好吧。有些信息量过大了。是的。关于吉姆和帕姆。我知道。
That was a must shoot. So you shot that. It exists somewhere. Wow. You shot us so much more than we need to know about their private life, I think. I have noticed in the shooting draft, whenever we get to the alts, that sometimes they do peel back a layer to Jim and Pam, and they always back away from it. They always end up not picking it.
那是一个必须拍摄的片段。所以你们拍了那个。它存在于某个地方。哇。我想你们拍了太多我们不需要知道的关于他们私生活的内容。我注意到在拍摄草稿中，每当我们遇到备选方案时，有时他们确实会揭开吉姆和帕姆的一层外衣，但他们总是退缩。他们最终总是选择不采用。
Well, now we're going to go into the conference room, and Gabe is going to play an introduction video. It is a video about the new company that has acquired them, Saber, and it is starring Christian Slater, as Christian Slater. I know. Michael has never been more impressed. Oh, he, I mean, now he's so excited about this company. Oh yeah.
好吧，现在我们要进入会议室了，盖博要播放一段介绍视频。这是一个关于收购他们的新公司赛博的视频，由克里斯蒂安·史莱特主演，饰演克里斯蒂安·史莱特。我知道。迈克尔从未如此印象深刻。哦，他，我的意思是，现在他对这家公司太兴奋了。哦，是的。
I thought we needed to hear it. So you've just been bought by Saber, probably a lot of questions. Hi, I'm Christian Slater. What's it like to work for Saber? Let's find out together. Being at Saber means taking on the challenge of the road that rises to meet you. Saber, respecting the past, but opening the window to the future. Have you ever tasted a rainbow?
我想我们需要听听。所以你们刚刚被赛博收购了，可能有很多问题。嗨，我是克里斯蒂安·史莱特。为赛博工作是什么感觉？让我们一起找出答案。在赛博意味着迎接通往你的道路的挑战。赛博，尊重过去，但打开通往未来的窗户。你尝过彩虹的味道吗？
Can Saber? You will. You'll find it easy to embrace the Saber spirit. Welcome. We're very excited to go on this journey with you. Okay, can I say something? This video opens with the line, so you've just been bought by Saber. How many companies have they bought?
赛博能吗？你会的。你会发现拥抱赛博精神很容易。欢迎。我们非常高兴能与你们一起踏上这段旅程。好吧，我能说点什么吗？这个视频以这句话开头，所以你们刚刚被赛博收购了。他们收购了多少家公司？
That's what I want to know. Is this something they made just for this acquisition, or is this like a thing they have? No, they've bought so many companies and had odd transitions, they had to make the video. That's my theory. Well, we got a lot of mail, a fan mail flurry asking, how did we get Christian Slater to star in this crazy video?
这就是我想知道的。这是他们专门为这次收购制作的，还是他们本来就有的东西？不，他们收购了太多公司，经历了奇怪的过渡，他们不得不制作这个视频。这是我的理论。好吧，我们收到了很多邮件，一堆粉丝来信问，我们是怎么让克里斯蒂安·史莱特出演这个疯狂视频的？
Well I found an interview that Christian Slater did for Entertainment Weekly about his experience on our show. Here's what he had to say. John Krasinski directed the episode, and he and I sort of know each other from different types of events, and he's a really nice dude. He called my agent and was wondering if I'd be available to do this fantastic PSA on Saber, the company that bought Dunder Mifflin. And somehow it worked out with the schedule.
我找到了克里斯蒂安·史莱特为《娱乐周刊》做的关于他在我们节目中经历的采访。这是他要说的。约翰·卡拉辛斯基执导了这一集，他和我在不同类型的活动中认识，他是个非常好的家伙。他给我的经纪人打了电话，想知道我是否有空拍摄这个关于赛博的精彩公益广告，赛博就是收购了邓德·米芬的公司。不知何故，时间安排上成功了。
It was kind of incredible. Wow, so John did it. John made it happen. Way to go. Well Johnson in an audio clip about what it was like to work with Christian Slater, here it is. One of the greatest memories for me in directing this episode was directing that industrial video for Saber.
这真是太不可思议了。哇，所以是约翰做的。约翰促成了这件事。干得好。好吧，约翰在一段音频片段中谈到了与克里斯蒂安·史莱特合作的感觉，就在这里。执导这一集对我来说最美好的回忆之一就是执导那个赛博的工业视频。
I mean, just being on set with Christian Slater was a pretty big highlight of my career. Not only was he one of my favorite actors growing up, but he was the nicest, nicest human being. And he was such a big fan of the show, and you could tell, he actually just exuded this excitement to be on set, totally understood the joke, and knew what he was doing. And it was just so much fun. Well Randy Cordray also shared with us that Christian Slater was a dream to work with, a total professional, cordial, friendly, and engaging with everyone on set.
我的意思是，能和克里斯蒂安·史莱特在片场本身就是我职业生涯中的一个亮点。他不仅是我成长过程中最喜欢的演员之一，而且还是最善良、最善良的人。他是这个节目的超级粉丝，你可以看出来，他实际上散发出一种在片场的兴奋感，完全理解这个笑话，并且知道自己在做什么。这真的太有趣了。好吧，兰迪·科德雷也和我们分享说，克里斯蒂安·史莱特合作起来简直是梦想，非常专业、亲切、友好，并且与片场的所有人都互动良好。
And Randy said, when we wrapped his work, I witnessed Christian giving up his seat in a courtesy shuttle van so that the entire hair and makeup team could travel together. Well that's a Steve Carell move right there. I know, so classy. We did not get to meet Christian Slater. We didn't get to work with him, we were so bummed. We were majorly bummed. Because everyone was talking about what a nice guy he was.
兰迪说，当我们结束他的工作时，我目睹了克里斯蒂安在礼宾班车上让出座位，以便整个发型和化妆团队可以一起旅行。好吧，那真是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔式的举动。我知道，太有格调了。我们没能见到克里斯蒂安·史莱特。我们没能和他一起工作，我们太沮丧了。我们非常沮丧。因为每个人都在谈论他是个多么好的人。
Well we got a fan question from Natasha in Wales. Where was the Christian Slater sequence shot? Was it close by? I got a location breakdown from Randy Cordray. Do it. The interior shots, including the cafeteria, which by the way, I asked Randy, was that the Ikea cafeteria? It really looks like my Ikea cafeteria.
好吧，我们收到了来自威尔士娜塔莎的粉丝提问。克里斯蒂安·史莱特的片段是在哪里拍摄的？离得近吗？我从兰迪·科德雷那里得到了地点明细。说吧。室内镜头，包括自助餐厅，顺便说一句，我问过兰迪，那是宜家自助餐厅吗？它看起来真的很像我的宜家自助餐厅。
It really does. We go to the same one. I was like, where are the meatballs? That looks like the cafeteria. He said no. They were filmed at the Lakeview Corporate Center in Westlake Village, California. He said that they were mostly unoccupied at the time, so we were able to dress them to look like whatever we needed.
真的很像。我们去的是同一家。我说，肉丸在哪里？那看起来像自助餐厅。他说不。它们是在加利福尼亚州西湖村的湖景企业中心拍摄的。他说当时大部分地方都是空置的，所以我们能够把它们布置成我们需要任何样子。
We made that cafeteria. The exterior shots were shot at the Baxter building. Randy complimented our locations manager, Kyle Alexander, because he was able to find these two spots right next to one another. It made it really easy to shoot those sequences in one day. And John shared that when they got to the location, that exterior location, there was a pond in front of the building, and it had a bunch of ducks in it, like 30 ducks. And John was super excited.
我们制作了那个自助餐厅。外景是在巴克斯特大楼拍摄的。兰迪称赞了我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大，因为他能在彼此旁边找到这两个地点。这使得在一天内拍摄这些片段变得非常容易。约翰分享说，当他们到达那个地点，那个外景地点时，大楼前有一个池塘，里面有一群鸭子，大约30只。约翰超级兴奋。
He absolutely loved this detail. So he put Christian Slater's opening shot right in front of the pond with the ducks. But right before they were about to shoot, one of the location guys got into the pond because they were trying to get the ducks to come just a little bit closer to camera. But guess what? All the ducks flew away. They were like, get out of our pond, Mr. John was so bummed. And then our writer, Jen Salata, shared that Greg Daniels pitched that line, have you ever
他非常喜欢这个细节。所以他把克里斯蒂安·史莱特的开场镜头直接放在了有鸭子的池塘前。但在他们准备拍摄之前，其中一个外景工作人员进入了池塘，因为他们试图让鸭子离摄像机更近一点。但你猜怎么着？所有的鸭子都飞走了。它们好像在说，离开我们的池塘，先生。约翰太沮丧了。然后我们的编剧珍·萨拉塔分享说，格雷格·丹尼尔斯提出了那句台词，你尝过
tasted a rainbow? Oh my gosh, so brilliant. That was from Greg. It was even used in the promo that you played. They did have some alts like, have you ever tasted a smile? But ultimately they kept the rainbow line. They also experimented with different things that Christians Slater could be doing on that line.
彩虹的味道吗？天哪，太天才了。那是格雷格想出来的。它甚至用在了你播放的宣传片里。他们确实有一些备选方案，比如，你尝过微笑的味道吗？但最终他们保留了彩虹那句台词。他们还尝试了克里斯蒂安·史莱特在那句台词中可以做的不同事情。
Like at one point, I guess they had him carrying around a giant basket of fruit. But they loved him picking up the sandwich. Yeah. I mean, they must have had so much fun shooting. They were just doing these weird, absurd things. And Christian was playing it so straight the whole time. It's amazing. Well, in the Entertainment Weekly article he did, the interviewer asked him if he ad-libbed
比如有一次，我猜他们让他提着一大篮水果。但他们喜欢他拿起三明治的样子。是的。我的意思是，他们拍摄时一定玩得很开心。他们只是在做这些奇怪、荒谬的事情。而克里斯蒂安全程都演得非常正经。太神奇了。好吧，在他做的《娱乐周刊》文章中，采访者问他是否即兴发挥了
anything, commenting that the thumbs up at the end was classic. Oh. Here was Christian's response. The thumbs up was a spontaneous moment. I just kind of thought, what would be the cheesiest thing to do? John wanted it to really look like Kathy Bates paid for this actor to come in and directed him on what to do behind the scenes. So I just kept thinking, what would Kathy Bates tell me to do?
任何东西，评论说最后的竖大拇指是经典。哦。这是克里斯蒂安的回应。竖大拇指是一个自发的时刻。我只是想，什么是最俗气的做法？约翰希望它看起来真的像是凯西·贝茨付钱让这个演员过来，并在幕后指导他该做什么。所以我一直在想，凯西·贝茨会告诉我做什么？
I love that motivation. Of course, Kathy Bates is Joe Bennett. Yes, exactly. Well, we had a fan question from Fiona L. in Melbourne, Australia. Our fan questions are very international today. I know. Well, actually, Fiona has something to tell us, which is that Christian Slater does ads very similar to the Saber introduction video.
我喜欢那种动机。当然，凯西·贝茨就是乔·贝内特。是的，没错。好吧，我们收到了来自澳大利亚墨尔本菲奥娜·L的粉丝提问。我们的粉丝提问今天非常国际化。我知道。好吧，其实菲奥娜有话要告诉我们，那就是克里斯蒂安·史莱特做的广告和赛博介绍视频非常相似。
They are for HP Wolf Security. They seem very tongue-in-cheek, especially because he's done this Saber video. I have never seen this commercial. I want to say thank you, Fiona, for sending me down the rabbit hole that is the Wolf HP web series. It was a web series that they launched in 2017, starring Christian Slater. They're called the Wolf. And I think Christian Slater is the Wolf because he howls in it.
它们是为惠普狼安全做的。它们看起来非常讽刺，尤其是因为他拍了这个赛博视频。我从来没见过这个广告。我想对菲奥娜说声谢谢，感谢你让我掉进了狼惠普网络系列的兔子洞。这是一个他们在2017年推出的网络系列，由克里斯蒂安·史莱特主演。它们被称为狼。我想克里斯蒂安·史莱特就是那只狼，因为他在里面嚎叫。
What? He howls. He walks through companies kind of like he does in the Saber video, you know, like he walks through the conference room while a meeting is happening. And all the while, he is highlighting how easily it would be for him to hack in to this company's printer or their computer. He sort of narrates as he's walking through iPoldeclip. Sheep never realizes a wolf around until it's too late.
什么？他嚎叫。他走过公司，就像他在赛博视频里做的那样，你知道，就像他在会议进行时走过会议室一样。而与此同时，他强调了黑进这家公司的打印机或电脑是多么容易。他一边走一边叙述。羊永远不会意识到狼在身边，直到为时已晚。
And they do exactly what the wolf expects them to do. They run into each other. They fall down. They become dinner. Time to eat. I've got no idea I used my phone to hack the OS on that printer over there. And why would they? Not one printer in this place has built-in malware protection.
他们完全按照狼的预期去做。他们撞到对方。他们摔倒。他们成了晚餐。开饭了。我不知道我用手机黑进了那台打印机的操作系统。他们为什么要那样做？这个地方没有一台打印机有内置的恶意软件保护。
Now, while they're all busy watching a little something I threw up on the control panel, just look at your screen. I can intercept all their print jobs until I find the info I'm looking for. Today's somebody's birthday. Perfect. A really good stuff is upstairs, the kind of stuff that could destroy any future this grand financial institution could hope to have. No!
现在，当他们都忙着看我在控制面板上扔的一点东西时，看看你的屏幕。我可以拦截他们所有的打印作业，直到找到我想要的信息。今天是某人的生日。完美。真正的好东西在楼上，那种可以摧毁这个宏伟金融机构未来希望的东西。不！
Do you hear all the sheep noise? I can't talk. Because all those people, the workers, they're just sheep. They're just... Oh, my gosh. And he's wolfing, you know? And then he howls. That is the most dramatic over-the-top corporate commercial I think I've ever heard.
你听到所有的羊叫声了吗？我不能说话。因为那些人，工人们，他们只是羊。他们只是……天哪。他在狼嚎，你知道吗？然后他嚎叫。我认为这是我听过的最戏剧性、最夸张的企业广告。
We only could hear it. Sam and I are dying laughing. We don't have a visual. Just like you guys listening. Oh, my gosh. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you guys, each one is like a few minutes long.
我们只能听到它。萨姆和我笑得要死。我们没有视觉画面。就像你们听众一样。天哪。是的。是的。我的意思是，你们，每一个都有几分钟长。
It was a whole series. Oh, my gosh. And I love, like, really dramatically when he's like, they have no idea. I just hacked him. Yeah. To their phone. Well, listen. I didn't know that you could hack into a printer until I watched this video.
这是一个完整的系列。天哪。我喜欢，当他非常戏剧性地说，他们根本不知道。我刚刚黑了他们。是的。到他们的手机。好吧，听着。在看这个视频之前，我不知道你可以黑进打印机。
That's what he's doing in this clip. He's hacking the printer. Anything can be hacked. Anything can be hacked, guys. I learned something. And I guess they just re-upped this campaign, so look for it. Well, remember years ago when we found out that you could hack someone's camera in their computer.
这就是他在这个片段里做的。他在黑打印机。任何东西都可以被黑。任何东西都可以被黑，伙计们。我学到了一些东西。我猜他们刚刚重新启动了这个活动，所以留意一下。好吧，还记得几年前我们发现你可以黑进别人电脑里的摄像头吗？
And so then we started putting post-it notes over our cameras. Over our camera. Uh-huh. I know everyone, you should do that. You should put a post-it note over the little camera in your computer. Right. Or a piece of tape or what have you. Yes, because we read that article where you can hack into it and then people just watch
然后我们就开始在摄像头上贴便利贴。在我们的摄像头上。嗯哼。我知道大家，你们应该这样做。你应该在电脑的小摄像头上贴一张便利贴。对。或者一块胶带什么的。是的，因为我们读过那篇文章，说你可以黑进去，然后人们只是看着
you in your house. How creepy. It's creep skis. Super creeper. All right. So back to the conference room. Mm-hmm. Gabe has shown the video.
你在家里。多毛骨悚然。太诡异了。超级恐怖。好吧。回到会议室。嗯哼。盖博播放了视频。
People are digesting it. Jim has a sarcastic talking head about it. With a great impression by John Krasinski. Very good. Well, you know he's good at the impressions. Mm-hmm. Well, now Gabe is going to explain that Saber primarily sells printers. So he wants everybody to consider themselves printer salesmen who also sell paper.
人们正在消化它。吉姆对此有一个讽刺的谈话环节。约翰·卡拉辛斯基模仿得很好。非常好。好吧，你知道他擅长模仿。嗯哼。好吧，现在盖博要解释说赛博主要销售打印机。所以他希望每个人都把自己视为也卖纸的打印机推销员。
Michael doesn't like this. He doesn't care for it. It's about to get worse for Michael, though. Gabe then starts going over all the new company policies. At six minutes, 58 seconds, Meredith yells, talk about vacation days. Such a like odd heckle from Meredith. This was a much longer scene where everyone shares about their vacation days. And Jenna, it just cracked me up.
迈克尔不喜欢这样。他不在乎。不过迈克尔的情况要变得更糟了。盖博随后开始检查所有的新公司政策。在6分58秒时，梅雷迪思大喊，谈谈假期。梅雷迪思的这种 heckle（起哄）真是奇怪。这是一个长得多的场景，每个人都分享了他们的假期。珍娜，这让我笑死了。
I want to share a little bit with you. Meredith says, I saved up days from last year. I want to go to Jamaica and then she stands up, rolls her hips and says, how Meredith got her groove back. Okay. Mm-hmm. Stanley has a talking head where he says, I need those vacation days. I have two women.
我想和你分享一点。梅雷迪思说，我存了去年的假期。我想去牙买加，然后她站起来，扭动臀部说，梅雷迪思是如何找回状态的。好的。嗯哼。斯坦利有一个谈话环节，他说，我需要那些假期。我有两个女人。
One likes to ski and one likes the tropics. It's very difficult. But I am not complaining or asking to be judged. I just need some time off. Okay. And then Michael says, what have you been saving up for days like a big trip in the future, like a 40 day family safari? Oh, Michael.
一个喜欢滑雪，一个喜欢热带。这很难。但我不是在抱怨或要求被评判。我只是需要一些时间休息。好的。然后迈克尔说，你一直在存假期是为了什么，比如未来的大旅行，比如40天的家庭游猎？哦，迈克尔。
Gabe says, I'm sorry, but maybe you could look into a two week safari for your family. And Michael says, you can't take 12 kids on a safari in only two weeks. And Stanley says, you can if they're imaginary. Oh, and then Kelly explains, she actually owes the company days because she tried out for American Idol and took time off. She went to Atlanta, Boston and Cincinnati and she did not advance. These are amazing. I know, but here's my favorite part.
盖博说，对不起，但也许你可以考虑为你的家人安排两周的游猎。迈克尔说，你不能在短短两周内带12个孩子去游猎。斯坦利说，如果他们是想象出来的，你就可以。哦，然后凯利解释说，她实际上欠公司假期，因为她参加了《美国偶像》的试镜并请了假。她去了亚特兰大、波士顿和辛辛那提，但她没有晋级。这些太棒了。我知道，但这是我最喜欢的部分。
This scene would have ended with a line from Creed and I am so bummed it got cut. While they're talking about their vacation time and whether it will roll over or not for Saber, Meredith sees the IT guy, right? Yes. And she says, Hey, who the hell is going through our stuff? And Creed says, Oh, that's just Sam. He's with me. What?
这一幕本来会以克里德的一句台词结束，我很遗憾它被剪掉了。当他们谈论他们的假期以及它是否会转到赛博时，梅雷迪思看到了IT人员，对吧？是的。她说，嘿，到底是谁在翻我们的东西？克里德说，哦，那是萨姆。他和我在一块。什么？
And then Gabe goes, actually, that's Nick, your new IT guy. And then the scene progresses as aired, but I just love that Creed thought he knew this guy. He's like, Oh, that's Sam. He's with me. Well, here is something that a lot of people flagged. When we cut over to Nick, the new IT guy, many people noticed that it is the same person who was giving graphic design career advice to Pam at the job fair.
然后盖博说，其实，那是尼克，你们的新IT人员。然后场景按播出那样进行，但我只是喜欢克里德以为他认识这个人。他说，哦，那是萨姆。他和我在一块。好吧，这是很多人标记出来的事情。当我们切到尼克，新IT人员时，许多人注意到他就是那个在招聘会上给帕姆提供平面设计职业建议的人。
Yeah. I asked Randy about this and he said, well, now job fair was not on his watch, but he did remember that a lot of the writers really, really loved this actor who, by the way, Nelson Franklin, who previously appeared in job fair, and they just decided we don't care. We're going to bring him back because this is now an arc. He's going to appear in four episodes as Nick. He's really an amazing comedic actor. You've probably seen him on Black-ish, Veep, Arrested Development, and, Angela, you know
是的。我问过兰迪这件事，他说，好吧，招聘会不在他的管辖范围内，但他确实记得很多编剧真的非常喜欢这个演员，顺便说一句，尼尔森·富兰克林，他之前出现在招聘会里，他们只是决定我们不在乎。我们要让他回来，因为这现在是一个弧线。他将以尼克的身份出现在四集里。他真的是一位了不起的喜剧演员。你可能在《黑人一家亲》、《副总统》、《发展受阻》中见过他，而且，安吉拉，你知道
him because you guys were both on Black AF together. We were. There was just the craziest little office reunion. Ken Quapas directed our episode. Nelson and I played writers in a writer's room. It's so funny. So funny. And then Rashida plays Kenya's wife, and we all were there on the same day.
他，因为你们俩都在《Black AF》里。我们都在。这简直是办公室最疯狂的小聚会。肯·夸帕斯执导了我们这一集。尼尔森和我在编剧室里扮演编剧。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。然后拉什达扮演肯尼亚的妻子，我们都在同一天在那里。
Well, we had a blast. Nelson's great. I was excited he got to come back. Me too. I really liked him. His character is going through our computers, and he's going to put up, like, blockers so that we can't waste time on certain websites. I mean, when he says YouTube, it looked like Michael pooped himself a little.
好吧，我们玩得很开心。尼尔森很棒。我很高兴他能回来。我也是。我真的很喜欢他。他的角色正在检查我们的电脑，他要设置拦截器，这样我们就不能在某些网站上浪费时间了。我的意思是，当他说YouTube时，看起来迈克尔有点吓尿了。
Very upset. But wait, there's more. It doesn't stop there. Gabe has even more new policies. But before we do that, I think we should take a break. I need to use the restroom. Okay. You're not going to argue with me.
非常不安。但等等，还有更多。还没完。盖博还有更多新政策。但在我们做那个之前，我想我们应该休息一下。我需要去洗手间。好的。你不会和我争论的。
I appreciate it. I will never argue with you for having to pee. You know this about me. It's one of our company policies. Pee whenever you need to. Go to the bathroom. You go to the bathroom. That's right.
我很感激。我永远不会因为你要撒尿而和你争论。你了解我这一点。这是我们的公司政策之一。随时需要就撒尿。去洗手间。你去洗手间。没错。
We are back. My bladder is empty. Your bladder is empty. Night. Have a donut. That's one brand for you, lady. Someone brought donuts today. It was my happiest moment of my day so far.
我们回来了。我的膀胱空了。你的膀胱空了。晚上好。吃个甜甜圈。那是给你的一个品牌，女士。今天有人带了甜甜圈。这是我今天到目前为止最快乐的时刻。
But only half of it. You only ever eat half of anything. That's right. Well, listen, Gabe is in the conference room, and his next new announcement is that he is going to give each employee an aluminum saber water bottle. This is going to eliminate the need for plastic. It's going to be really good for the environment. But Michael is like upset.
但只有一半。你吃任何东西都只吃一半。没错。好吧，听着，盖博在会议室里，他的下一个新公告是他要给每个员工一个铝制赛博水瓶。这将消除对塑料的需求。这对环境真的很好。但迈克尔很不高兴。
He's like, what about my little cups? Like my little cups, I drink the water out of. He drinks 20 a day. Now here's the thing that I think is kind of brilliant. Because Gabe says, I bet you can fit those 20 little cups into your water bottle. And Michael says, but what about the 20 little trips that I take to the water cooler each day where he scans the office or his 20 little conversations with Stanley? Or Stanley?
他说，那我的小杯子呢？就像我喝水用的小杯子。他一天喝20个。现在这里有一件事我觉得有点天才。因为盖博说，我打赌你可以把那20个小杯子装进你的水瓶里。迈克尔说，但我每天去饮水机的那20次小旅行怎么办，他在那里扫描办公室，或者他与斯坦利的20次小谈话？或者斯坦利？
Stanley's like, I can let go. All this time. Stanley, like unbeknownst to us, he's having 20 conversations a day with Michael because he sits by the water cooler. I'm surprised he hasn't moved the water cooler personally. That Stanley didn't move it like back into the annex. I'm surprised Stanley hasn't requested to like trade seats with Creed. Truly.
斯坦利说，我可以放手。一直以来。斯坦利，在我们不知情的情况下，他每天和迈克尔进行20次谈话，因为他坐在饮水机旁边。我很惊讶他没有亲自把饮水机搬走。斯坦利没有把它搬回附楼。我很惊讶斯坦利没有要求和克里德换座位。真的。
Well, he likes his relationship with Phyllis. We know that. That's his work wife. I just want to say, I think it's actually a little genius, the trip to the water cooler as a managerial technique. I was like, oh, smart. If Michael really wanted to manage people, he just gets bored. That's true.
好吧，他喜欢他和菲利斯的关系。我们知道这一点。那是他的工作妻子。我只想说，我认为去饮水机作为一种管理技巧其实有点天才。我当时想，哦，聪明。如果迈克尔真的想管理员工，他只是感到无聊。那是真的。
It's probably driven from another place. Well, at seven minutes, 28 seconds, if you look at the Saber water bottle, that was made by Clean Canteen. Oh, a little tidbit from Randy Cordray, and they also applied the logo that was designed by Henry Sain. I guess there were many, many variations of the Saber logo that Greg and Paul had to choose from, and that's the one they picked, but Jenna, yeah, the whole time I was watching the scene, all I could remember was we did this.
这可能是从别的地方驱动的。好吧，在7分28秒时，如果你看赛博水瓶，那是Clean Canteen制造的。哦，来自兰迪·科德雷的一个小花絮，他们还应用了亨利·塞恩设计的标志。我猜格雷格和保罗必须从中选择很多很多赛博标志的变体，那是他们选中的那个，但珍娜，是的，我观看这一幕的整个过程中，我能记住的只有我们做了这个。
We did this. Yes. Paul Lieberstein made us all drink out of these canteens. Yes, and I was like, wait, I know I have something in my digital clutter about this. Some email saying that we were getting rid of plastic water bottles. I knew I had something in my digital clutter about this. Sam. Angela's digital clutter.
我们做了这个。是的，保罗·利伯斯坦让我们都用这些水壶喝水。是的，我当时想，等等，我知道我的数字杂物里有关于这个的东西。有些邮件说我们要摆脱塑料水瓶。我知道我的数字杂物里有关于这个的东西。萨姆。安吉拉的数字杂物。
Oh, my God. So Jenna, we all got an email during this time that there wouldn't be plastic water bottles on set. Yes. Yes. A stainless steel water bottle that said Dunder Mifflin on it, and we were going to refill them throughout the day. So Jenna, you remembered so quickly it was Paul.
天哪。所以珍娜，我们当时都收到了一封邮件，说片场不会有塑料水瓶。是的。是的。一个上面写着邓德·米芬的不锈钢水瓶，我们要全天补充它们。所以珍娜，你记得这么快，是保罗。
I couldn't remember if it was Paul or Brent, because I remember Brent was very much about being healthy and eco-friendly. Yes. I texted Brent. Brent was this you. He was like, no, I'm pretty sure it was Paul. So then I emailed Paul, and I said, Paul, I know we did this, right? I found in my digital clutter, was this your idea, and was it also part of the inspiration
我不记得是保罗还是布伦特了，因为我记得布伦特非常注重健康和环保。是的。我给布伦特发了短信。布伦特，这是你吗？他说，不，我很确定是保罗。所以我给保罗发了邮件，我说，保罗，我知道我们做了这个，对吧？我在我的数字杂物里发现了，这是你的主意吗，它也是
for Gabe and his saber water bottles? And this is what Paul had to say. Paul said, yes, I tried to get us to be plastic free. It worked for a little while. I remember that too. It was very short lived. I know. He said, as far as it being an intended storyline for Gabe, he doesn't have a clear memory
盖博和他的赛博水瓶的灵感来源吗？这就是保罗要说的。保罗说，是的，我试图让我们实现无塑料。它确实起作用了一段时间。我也记得那个。它非常短暂。我知道。他说，至于它是否是盖博的预期故事情节，他没有清晰的记忆
that that was specifically a Gabe storyline, but in general, so much of what was happening around us was inspiration for the show. All right. I was probably connected, but I was like, oh my gosh, we did this. Do you know what I remembered? What? Standing in line to refill it. There literally was a line.
那是专门的盖博故事情节，但总的来说，我们周围发生的很多事情都是节目的灵感来源。好吧。我可能有关联，但我当时想，天哪，我们做了这个。你知道我记得什么吗？什么？排队去补充它。真的有一条队。
Yes. Well, Paul told me that this was sort of a craze that was happening during this time. Companies were really trying to limit plastic use, and so he wanted us to be a part of that. I do think it's a great idea, but I think you need more than one refill jug area. That probably would have helped. That would have helped. Well, Michael has a talking head about all this where he says, okay, there's a small part of him that's excited about the new company, but 70% of him is water.
是的。好吧，保罗告诉我，这在当时是一种风潮。公司真的在努力限制塑料的使用，所以他希望我们成为其中的一部分。我确实认为这是一个好主意，但我认为你需要不止一个补充壶区。那可能会有帮助。那会有帮助。好吧，迈克尔对此有一个谈话环节，他说，好吧，他有一小部分对新公司感到兴奋，但70%的他都是水。
And at the end of this talking head, he says that he thinks these changes suck ball because you know what he was going to say. Sucks balls. It was so funny. I guess cutting off the end of Michael saying balls was an idea that John had. He came up with it in editing with Dave Rogers, and I love their take on this. So what they were saying was that obviously Michael completed his sentence, but they imagined that when the documentary aired that the documentarians would have left in all of the footage, but
在这个谈话环节结束时，他说他认为这些改变烂透了，因为你知道他本来要说什么。烂透了。太搞笑了。我猜剪掉迈克尔说球的结尾是约翰的一个主意。他在剪辑时和戴夫·罗杰斯一起想出来的，我喜欢他们对这个的看法。所以他们说的是，显然迈克尔完成了他的句子，但他们想象当纪录片播出时，纪录片制作人会留下所有的镜头，但
the network running the documentary would have to cut it off. Right, because of, you know, standards and practices. And he said they based that on the amount of times that we had to cut things or changed things because of standards and practices. Every episode probably. Very realistic. Well, listen, Angela, you mentioned the line to fill their water bottles. And while Michael is in line, Toby's getting water and it runs out.
运行纪录片的网络将不得不剪掉它。对，因为，你知道，标准和实践。他说他们是基于我们因为标准和实践而不得不剪掉东西或改变东西的次数。每一集可能都是。非常现实。好吧，听着，安吉拉，你提到了排队补充水瓶。当迈克尔在排队时，托比在喝水，水用完了。
Toby says we kicked it, which cracked me up. Me too. I wrote it down at eight minutes, 45 seconds. That's what you say when a keg runs out, right? I know. Well, what does that tell us about Toby? Well, I think what does it tell us about Paul? Because I've bought a pony keg with Paul and we've kicked it.
托比说我们把它踢了，这让我笑死了。我也是。我在8分45秒时把它写了下来。那是当小桶用完时你会说的话，对吧？我知道。好吧，那告诉了我们关于托比的什么？好吧，我想那告诉了我们关于保罗的什么？因为我和保罗买过一个小桶，我们把它踢了。
See, I would never use that language because I've never purchased a keg and I've never had a beer out of a keg. Oh, man. I'm not a beer person. Listen. Now I'll do a flavored ale or a cider beer. A really, really cold keg and like getting a beer out of a super cold keg. It's great, especially like on a hot day.
看，我永远不会用那种语言，因为我从来没买过小桶，也从来没从小桶里喝过啤酒。哦，伙计。我不是啤酒爱好者。听着。现在我会喝调味麦芽酒或苹果酒。一个非常非常冷的小桶，像从超级冷的小桶里拿啤酒。太棒了，尤其是在炎热的日子里。
Maybe you put one, you know, at second base because you're playing softball with friends and if you make it to second base, you get a beer and you get a little tooted while you're waiting to run into home plate. That cold beer out of a keg. It's amazing. I mean, that sounds miserable to me. You drink some beer and then you have to run on your sloshy beer stomach. Have you seen like co-ed softball like with a group of friends?
也许你把它放在，你知道，二垒，因为你和朋友打垒球，如果你到了二垒，你就能喝到啤酒，在你等着跑回本垒时你会有点醉。从小桶里拿出的那杯冷啤酒。太棒了。我的意思是，那听起来对我来说很痛苦。你喝了一些啤酒，然后你必须在你的啤酒胃上跑。你见过像和朋友一起的男女混合垒球吗？
This is not like real athleticism. You have lived part of life that I haven't lived. You've had all these experiences and to me it's like you lived in a foreign land. What? A foreign land of softball and beer? Yeah. I have no like frame of reference for that. I know you and Lee bond over this stuff all the time.
这不是真正的运动能力。你经历过我没经历过的生活。你经历过所有这些经历，对我来说就像你生活在外国。什么？垒球和啤酒的外国？是的。我对此没有任何参考框架。我知道你和李一直因为这些东西而建立联系。
Is this a Texas thing? I mean, I'm sure they're doing it in Missouri. No. What was I? It was during this time. This was just like a hip young person out in the world. I've never been a hip young person. Well, that's true.
这是德州的事情吗？我的意思是，我肯定他们在密苏里州也在做。不。我是什么？那是在这段时间。这就像一个时髦的年轻人在世界上。我从来不是一个时髦的年轻人。好吧，那是真的。
I've been a 65 year old woman since the day I was born. It's true and I love you for it. Thank you, lady. As I stare at your big fake flower that's on your lapel. I know it's not working. I know it's not working. I wore it in today because I wanted to prove to you that this cannot happen on our book launch tour.
我从出生那天起就是一个65岁的老太太。这是真的，我爱你这一点。谢谢你，女士。当我盯着你翻领上的大假花时。我知道它没用。我知道它没用。我今天戴着它是因为我想向你证明，这在我们的新书发布巡回演出中是不可能发生的。
It can't. Look at me. It's ridiculous. You never had. When you were coming out of this flower squirt, squirt, it's borderline clownish. It can't happen. You never had to prove it to me. I've known it from the beginning.
不可能。看着我。这太荒谬了。你从来没有。当你从这朵花里喷水时，喷水，这近乎小丑。不可能发生。你从来不需要向我证明。我从一开始就知道。
Well, I needed to prove it to myself. All right. Where are we? Well, Toby has just kicked the water cooler. Oh, yes. That's right. Well, now Michael's going to confront Gabe. He's going to say, listen, I don't mean to seem ungrateful, but I am really struggling
好吧，我需要向自己证明。好吧。我们在哪里？好吧，托比刚刚踢了饮水机。哦，是的。没错。好吧，现在迈克尔要和盖博对质。他要说，听着，我不想显得不知感恩，但我真的很挣扎
to embrace some of these changes such as all of them. Gabe says it's kind of above his pay grade. He can't really change any of the policies, but he'll see what he can do. And now Pam and Jim are going to enter the daycare center. All of these scenes were absolutely delicious. I loved watching them. We had a fan question from Alice R in Italy. Where did you shoot the daycare scenes?
去拥抱其中一些改变，比如所有这些。盖博说这有点超出他的薪水等级。他不能真正改变任何政策，但他会看看他能做什么。现在帕姆和吉姆要进入日托中心了。所有这些场景都绝对美味。我喜欢看它们。我们收到了来自意大利爱丽丝·R的粉丝提问。你们在哪里拍摄日托场景？
Was it a real daycare? Did you make any changes? Lady, did you recognize it? No. OK. Well, it's called Sandbox Daycare. We made that up. That's not even a real daycare in Scranton.
那是真正的日托吗？你们做了什么改变吗？女士，你认出来了吗？不。好的。好吧，它叫沙盒日托。那是我们编的。那甚至不是斯克兰顿真正的日托。
We shot this at Peek-a-boo Playland in Eagle Rock, California. Did you not take Isabel to Peek-a-boo Playland? Was that after she was a toddler? This was all the rage when my kids were little. Eagle Rock's far from me. I guess that's true. We had tons and tons of Playland-type places right by me, so I never needed to venture this far.
我们在加利福尼亚州鹰岩的Peek-a-boo游乐场拍摄了这个。你没带伊莎贝尔去Peek-a-boo游乐场吗？那是她蹒跚学步之后吗？当我的孩子小的时候，这非常流行。鹰岩离我很远。我猜那是真的。我附近有成吨成吨的游乐场类型的地方，所以我从来不需要冒险走这么远。
Well, you know, when I did this episode, I didn't have kids. But then when I was rewatching it, I was like, it's Peek-a-boo. It's Peek-a-boo Playland. I've spent so many days in this space. See the one by me is the coop. I spent tons of time at the coop. Oh, the coop. I've been to the coop.
好吧，你知道，当我拍这一集时，我没有孩子。但后来当我重看它时，我当时想，这是Peek-a-boo。这是Peek-a-boo游乐场。我在这个空间里度过了很多天。看我旁边的那个是合作社。我在合作社度过了很多时间。哦，合作社。我去过合作社。
Yeah. All right. So there's a big twirly slide in the middle. Yeah. There's like a tree house around the curly slide. It's the cutest dang thing. When we get there, Jim and Pam are totally charmed, except Jim accidentally walks in on the daycare director who is using the little kitty toilet.
是的。好吧。所以中间有一个大的旋转滑梯。是的。旋转滑梯周围有一个树屋。这是最可爱的东西。当我们到达那里时，吉姆和帕姆完全被迷住了，除了吉姆不小心闯入了正在使用小猫厕所的日托主任。
Those toilets are so low to the ground. Well, they need to be because the little children. I know, but seeing a grown man on it really did. I was like, oh my God. John sent us in an audio clip of what it was like to shoot in the daycare. Here's what he had to say. My other favorite memory from that episode was the interview at the daycare center. Jenna, as we've talked about many times, and I won't embarrass you on your own show,
那些厕所离地面太低了。好吧，它们需要这样，因为小孩子。我知道，但看到一个成年男人在上面确实。我当时想，天哪。约翰给我们发了一段关于在日托中心拍摄是什么感觉的音频片段。这是他要说的。那一集我另一个最喜欢的记忆是日托中心的面试。珍娜，正如我们多次谈到的，我不会在你的节目上让你尴尬，
I apologize, but not really. Truly some of my favorite, favorite memories in all of my career. We're getting to do scenes with you, period. But especially those scenes where the two of us were sort of stuck in it together, that we were both in something that we had to get out of together. I remember very specifically your line reading when I came out from seeing Jerry in the bathroom, and I said, I just saw someone in the bathroom, and you very earnestly ask, who was it? Who was it?
我道歉，但其实也不是真的道歉。这确实是我整个职业生涯中最最珍贵的回忆之一。我们能和你一起演戏，这本身就很有意义。尤其是我们俩被困在一起，必须共同想办法脱身的那些场景。我特别记得当我从洗手间看到杰瑞出来时，你那句台词的演绎，我说，我刚在洗手间看到一个人，你非常认真地问，是谁？是谁？
And then you quickly digress as your brain realizes, oh, it was definitely the guy that we're about to interview. And your line reading of who was it? Who was it? Was it the guy who's going to interview us? It was so funny, and I don't know that I had a good enough take of my reaction to you. In fact, do I physically bail out after you say that to me? Man, that really made me laugh.
然后你很快就走神了，因为你的大脑意识到，哦，那肯定就是我们要面试的那个人。你那句“是谁？是谁？是那个要面试我们的人吗？”演得太搞笑了，我不知道我当时对你的反应有没有演好。事实上，你说完那句话后，我是不是真的落荒而逃了？天哪，那真的让我笑个不停。
I seem to remember going through, I don't know, 10, 12 takes of just not being able to keep it together. That was a total Gigglefest day for me. You were always more professional, but I was in full Gigglefest mode. And shout out to my friend, Joey Slotnik, who played Jerry. I was so excited to get him on the show, and he absolutely crushed it. That gesture he does in the bathroom, where he silently raises his hand, but there is no room.
我记得我好像拍了10到12条，就是因为一直憋不住笑。对我来说，那天简直就是“傻笑节”。你总是更专业，但我完全处于“傻笑节”模式。还要向我的朋友乔伊·斯洛特尼克致敬，他饰演了杰瑞。我很高兴能让他上节目，他演得太棒了。他在洗手间做的那个手势，他默默地举起手，但空间根本不够。
There is nothing said between the two people. Just utter shame and embarrassment and guilt. He was so great on that show, and I just remember yet again, just getting to watch those scenes and not have to give any notes. All right, so I just have to say, I totally remember that. Yes, John, you do physically bail out of the scene. But also, you know what? I really appreciate him saying that he liked shooting these scenes with me, because I think
两人之间什么都没说。只有彻底的羞耻、尴尬和内疚。他在那集里表现得太棒了，我记得我当时又一次看着那些场景，根本不需要给任何指导。好吧，我必须说，我完全记得那个场景。是的，约翰，你确实从那个场景里落荒而逃了。但还有，你知道吗？我真的很感激他说喜欢和我一起拍这些戏，因为我觉得
there's often a lot written about our romantic chemistry on screen, but we had a really special comedic chemistry together. And I feel like this storyline really highlights that. We were great partners all around. I agree, and I loved what John said about when you guys were both in a sticky situation together. Yes, I loved it. And you know, John mentioned Jerry, the daycare director was played by Joey Slotnik.
关于我们在银幕上的浪漫化学反应有很多报道，但我们之间有一种非常特别的喜剧化学反应。我觉得这个故事情节很好地突显了这一点。我们是全方位的绝佳搭档。我同意，我也很喜欢约翰说的关于你们俩一起陷入困境的时候。是的，我喜欢。而且你知道，约翰提到的杰瑞，那个日托中心主任是由乔伊·斯洛特尼克扮演的。
He was a really good friend of John's. He had also been in John's movie, Brief Interviews with Hideous Men, but Joey had actually auditioned for this part through Ellison Jones. I guess he'd auditioned for other roles on the show. And when this role came up, she thought of him, and she knew he was John's friend. But you might recognize Joey from the TV shows Alias, Boston Public, The Single Guy, or Nip Tuck. He was also in the movie Twister and The Secret Life of Walter Middy, which, by the way, is
他是约翰的好朋友。他也出演过约翰的电影《丑陋男人简短访谈》，但乔伊其实是通过埃里森·琼斯试镜这个角色的。我想他之前也试镜过剧中的其他角色。当这个角色出现时，她想到了他，而且她知道他是约翰的朋友。但你可能在电视剧《双面女间谍》、《波士顿公立学校》、《单身男子》或《整容室》中认出乔伊。他还出演了电影《龙卷风》和《白日梦想家》，顺便说一句，这是
one of my favorite movies directed by Ben Stiller. Well, I met Joey years ago. When I first came to Los Angeles, my friend got me a job just for one season being a stand-in on The Single Guy. I didn't know you were a stand-in. Yeah, just for one season. Still. It was so cool.
我最喜欢的本·斯蒂勒导演的电影之一。嗯，我多年前就认识乔伊了。我刚到洛杉矶时，朋友帮我找了一份工作，在《单身男子》里做了一季的替身。我不知道你做过替身。是的，就一季。还是很酷的。
What a great way to learn the ins and out of a four-camera show. Yes, you know, I did background work for years when I first came out. Same. A great way to just sit on a set and observe how it works. So by the time I finally booked a role and I had a line, I was like, oh, I know the flow. Like I know some of the language. Yeah. I know this world.
了解四机位拍摄节目的来龙去脉真是太棒了。是的，你知道，我刚出来的时候做了好几年的背景演员。我也是。坐在片场观察它是如何运作的，这真是个好方法。所以当我终于接到一个有台词的角色时，我就想，哦，我了解流程。就像我知道一些术语一样。是的。我了解这个世界。
And four-camera stand-ins walk through the role while they're lighting. They say the lines that go to the mark. It was such a great education. And Joey was so nice to everyone. That's my memory of him. Well, we got some mail asking, why aren't there any kids at this daycare? Right. Well, there actually were.
四机位替身在打光时会走位。他们会说出走到标记点的台词。这真是一次很棒的教育。而且乔伊对每个人都很好。这就是我对他的记忆。好吧，我们收到了一些邮件问，为什么这个日托中心没有孩子？对。嗯，其实是有的。
The kids were staged doing a little story time, but they were over to the side. So when Pam and Jim arrive, there was like a mini scene of the kids doing story time and Pam and Jim have a little awe moment. And then John actually directed me when he was going to walk to the bathroom to go up to the little tea set and just be like pretending like I was a kid doing tea and I was like so charmed. And Jen shared that they really liked just following me and John rather than cutting away and showing the kids.
孩子们被安排在做讲故事时间，但他们在旁边。所以当帕姆和吉姆到达时，有一个孩子们做讲故事时间的小场景，帕姆和吉姆有一个小小的“哇”时刻。然后约翰在我要去洗手间时指导我，让我走到小茶具旁，假装自己是个在喝茶的孩子，我当时觉得太迷人了。珍分享说，他们真的很喜欢跟着我和约翰拍，而不是切走去拍孩子们。
So they actually edited out that story time bit for time because they just liked staying with our enthusiasm over the daycare center. Oh, yeah. I agree. You guys are just so delighted to be new parents. And I loved the line when Jim says, oh, cubbies, I forgot about cubbies. Yes. Because that's really how it is when you have kids.
所以他们实际上为了时长剪掉了讲故事的那部分，因为他们就是喜欢保持我们对日托中心的这种热情。哦，是的。我同意。你们俩作为新手父母真是太高兴了。我很喜欢吉姆说的那句台词，“哦，小隔间，我忘了小隔间了。”是的。因为当你有了孩子，情况确实就是这样。
All of these memories come back to you. It's true. Well, right after this Jim and Pam scene at the daycare would have been the second part of this accounting runner. The one where Angela is giving fake work to Kevin. Yes. I love it. All right.
所有的记忆都会涌上心头。这是真的。好吧，就在这个吉姆和帕姆在日托中心的场景之后，应该是这个会计支线的第二部分。就是安吉拉给凯文分配虚假工作的那部分。是的，我喜欢。好吧。
So it reads, interior vans refrigeration. Kevin approaches a desk where an older man is sitting. Kevin, excuse me, are you Todd? The old man says yes. Kevin says, I'm Kevin. I'm an accountant at Dundermifflin. Todd says, oh, you must know Phyllis. She's great.
剧本上写着，内景，万斯制冷公司。凯文走到一张桌子前，一个老人坐在那里。凯文：打扰一下，你是托德吗？老人说是。凯文说：我是凯文。我是邓德米夫林的会计。托德说：哦，你一定认识菲利斯。她很棒。
Kevin says Phyllis is, but I didn't come all the way over here to talk about Phyllis. Kevin closes the door on the cameras. What's happening? What's happening? Dun dun dun. Dun dun dun. Wow. I know.
凯文说菲利斯是很棒，但我不是大老远跑来谈论菲利斯的。凯文在摄像机前关上了门。发生了什么？发生了什么？咚咚咚。咚咚咚。哇。我知道。
Part three is coming up. Well, this is the part of the show where we're going to see Andy and Erin flirting in the kitchen. So awkward. So awkward. I wanted to point out that I really loved how during this scene Andy pulls a pizza. Out of the fridge. And it's in an Alfredo's Pizza Cafe pizza box.
第三部分要来了。好吧，这是节目中我们要看到安迪和艾琳在厨房调情的片段。太尴尬了。太尴尬了。我想指出，我真的很喜欢在这个场景中，安迪从冰箱里拿出一盒披萨。而且是在阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆的披萨盒里。
You know Phil Shea was all over that. It's the details. I know. It's in the details. The prop protege in me. Hmm. Notice these things. Saw that.
你知道菲尔·谢对此非常上心。这就是细节。我知道。细节决定成败。我体内的道具保护欲。嗯。注意到了这些。看到了。
Yes. I'm learning. I'm always learning. You're always learning. The next scene between Gabe and Joe Bennett on the computer is so good. And we meet Joe Bennett. Yes. Randy told me that we shot this in real time.
是的。我在学习。我一直在学习。你一直在学习。盖博和乔·贝内特在电脑上的下一场戏太棒了。我们见到了乔·贝内特。是的。兰迪告诉我我们是实时拍摄的。
No way. Yes. They set up a little Joe's office set right outside our main office stage. It's where our lunch tables would normally be. We shot it using Skype. Remember Skype? Yeah. It was like the first zoom.
不会吧。是的。他们在我们主办公室舞台外搭建了一个小小的乔的办公室布景。那是我们平时吃午饭桌子的地方。我们用Skype拍摄的。还记得Skype吗？是的。它就像最初的Zoom。
I remember this because Pam did some of these Skypes when she was at art school. And this internet at our studio could be really troublesome. And Randy told me they had to create an entirely new network just to make this Skype work with Kathy Bates and everyone in the cast and crew had to turn off their computers and put their phones on airplane mode. Just to get the signal strong enough. Yes. Otherwise it would break up.
我记得这个，因为帕姆在艺术学校时也用过Skype。我们工作室的互联网真的很麻烦。兰迪告诉我，他们必须创建一个全新的网络才能让这个Skype与凯西·贝茨连接，而且所有的演员和工作人员都必须关掉电脑，把手机调成飞行模式。只是为了让信号足够强。是的。否则信号会中断。
I totally remember that. Well, during this scene, Michael is lurking behind the laptop and eventually Gabe is going to turn the computer around and Joe Bennett is going to be like, what's up? Yeah. Hey, fella. She kind of tries to whistle. It's not a weak whistle. It's not a full whistle.
我完全记得那个。好吧，在这个场景中，迈克尔潜伏在笔记本电脑后面，最终盖博会把电脑转过来，乔·贝内特会说，怎么了？是的。嘿，伙计。她试图吹口哨。那不是弱弱的口哨。也不是完整的口哨。
It's okay, though. It's okay. Michael says that he doesn't want to do these changes, but Joe says she hasn't seen a company this poorly managed since her grandson's snowball company. Michael says, you know what? Maybe I could speak to Christian Slater. I bet he would know what to do. Michael.
不过没关系。没关系。迈克尔说他不想做这些改变，但乔说她还没见过管理得这么差的公司，除了她孙子的雪球公司。迈克尔说，你知道吗？也许我可以和克里斯蒂安·史莱特谈谈。我敢打赌他会知道该怎么做。迈克尔。
Come on. I mean, Michael, do you think Christian Slater is there? He's not there, Michael. He thinks he now works with Christian Slater. He does. He's imagining the Christmas party. Yeah. Joe says, why don't you take till the end of the day to decide if you can apply these
拜托。我是说，迈克尔，你觉得克里斯蒂安·史莱特在那里吗？他不在那儿，迈克尔。他以为他现在和克里斯蒂安·史莱特一起工作。他确实是。他在想象圣诞派对。是的。乔说，你为什么不考虑一下到今天结束时是否能执行这些
changes? And Michael's like, I don't need to think about it. I know I can't. And then she says, I think you should take till the end of the day. And then it becomes very clear that if the answer isn't yes, then you're out. He'll be fired. Yeah. God, it's some great managing.
改变？迈克尔说，我不需要考虑。我知道我做不到。然后她说，我觉得你应该考虑一下到今天结束。然后很明显，如果答案不是肯定的，那你就会被踢出局。他会被解雇。是的。天哪，这真是很棒的管理。
I mean, I just, I know, Joe Bennett is your kindred spirit. It's true. Michael's going to drive out of the parking lot, but not before he tosses his aluminum Saubre water bottle out the window. Yes. And it hits Stanley's windshield. Of course. I asked Randy Cordray, how did we do this broken window gag, and he said that the windshield
我是说，我只是，我知道，乔·贝内特是你的知己。这是真的。迈克尔要开车离开停车场，但在那之前，他把他的铝制Saubre水瓶扔出了窗外。是的。它撞到了斯坦利的挡风玻璃。当然。我问兰迪·科德雷，我们是怎么做这个破窗特技的，他说挡风玻璃
was pre-broken. I don't know if you notice, but you don't ever see the water bottle hit the windshield. You hear it, and then he drives by and you see it's broken. They did that because it was just too hard for Steve to, like, throw a water bottle with such force that it would actually crack a windshield. And accuracy if we learned anything about that watermelon on the trampoline. Oh my gosh. So many takes of watermelons.
是预先弄碎的。我不知道你有没有注意到，你从来没看到水瓶撞到挡风玻璃。你听到了声音，然后他开车经过，你看到它碎了。他们这样做是因为史蒂夫很难用力扔出一个水瓶，以至于真的能砸碎挡风玻璃。还有准确度，如果我们从蹦床上的那个西瓜学到了什么的话。天哪。拍了太多次西瓜了。
Randy said they just added a sound effect in post-production, and it really works. Back at the Daycare, Jerry, the Daycare director, is going to introduce himself. Oh my gosh, Jenna, John's performance is so good in this scene. Of course, he gives Pam a look like, yeah, that's the guy. That's the one I walked in on. And he can't, he cannot pull it together. He keeps putting his foot in his mouth. He goes to take a call and Pam's like, listen, you need to get it together.
兰迪说他们只是在后期制作中加了音效，效果真的很好。回到日托中心，杰瑞，日托中心主任，要自我介绍。天哪，珍娜，约翰在这个场景里的表演太棒了。当然，他给了帕姆一个眼神，好像在说，是的，就是那个家伙。就是我撞见的那个人。他无法，他无法控制自己。他一直在说错话。他去接个电话，帕姆说，听着，你需要振作起来。
So John said that he doesn't remember giving any pieces of direction, but he did give me a piece of direction in this scene, and I was so delighted to get it. He said that I should try saying that line. And that's the most awkward solution to the problem. Like a game show host might say it. Oh, isn't that a fun thing to play with? It is. And it was very not sort of what Pam normally sounds like.
所以约翰说他不记得给过任何指导，但他确实在这个场景中给了我一个指导，我很高兴得到它。他说我应该试着说那句台词。那是解决问题的最尴尬的方法。就像游戏节目主持人可能会说的那样。哦，那不是一个很有趣的玩法吗？是的。而且这听起来不太像帕姆平时的声音。
I loved it. I did too. I thought it was so funny. So let's continue on here. And Pam and Jim are going to be sitting in Jerry's office and they're having their interview. Oh my God, the scene is so good. It's so funny. It's so funny.
我喜欢。我也喜欢。我觉得太搞笑了。那么我们继续吧。帕姆和吉姆要坐在杰瑞的办公室里进行面试。天哪，这个场景太棒了。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。
Everyone plays every moment perfectly. Jim is going to ask about switching some holiday time. Yeah. What's their flexibility when it comes to, you know, vacation time? And Jerry says, you know what? If you get in, we can discuss that. And Pam is like, is this because he walked in on you in the bathroom? She just calls it out.
每个人都完美地演绎了每一个瞬间。吉姆要问关于调换一些假期时间的事。是的。他们在假期时间方面的灵活性如何？杰瑞说，你知道吗？如果你被录取了，我们可以讨论这个问题。帕姆说，这是因为他在洗手间撞见你了吗？她直接说了出来。
She just, she does exactly what Jim was going to do. And she was like, no, no, no, don't do that. That'd be awkward. But clearly it needs to be said. Right. I'm with Pam here. And Jerry's like, you told her? Like Jim and Jerry don't even know each other, but Jim broke some guy code.
她只是，她做了吉姆想做的事。她说，不，不，不，别那样做。那会很尴尬。但显然必须说出来。对。我支持帕姆。杰瑞说，你告诉她了？好像吉姆和杰瑞甚至不认识，但吉姆打破了某种男人准则。
I know. I love it. And Pam is like, I mean, it seems like this isn't going well, but it should be going well because we're really nice people. And Jerry says, you know what? Have you ever considered that you're not as charming as you think you are? Ouch. Wow.
我知道。我喜欢。帕姆说，我是说，看起来这不太顺利，但应该顺利的，因为我们真的是很好的人。杰瑞说，你知道吗？你有没有想过你并没有你想象中那么迷人？哎哟。哇。
Ouch. And Pam's like, no. Pam's like, I think we are as charming as we think we are. And Jim's like, why didn't you just lock the door? Yeah. And he's like, there's no lock because of the kids. Well, I'll have you know, I've been in that bathroom at that daycare center. There is a lock.
哎哟。帕姆说，没有。帕姆说，我觉得我们确实像我们想象中那么迷人。吉姆说，你为什么不锁门？是的。他说，因为孩子们，所以没有锁。好吧，我告诉你，我去过那个日托中心的洗手间。那里有锁。
It's up real high. Right. That's what you do. Right. You put it up real high that they can't reach it. My all-time daycare favorite moment might be at the end of the scene when Jim says anyone could have walked in there. And Jerry just goes, story time.
它在很高的地方。对。这就是你要做的。对。你把它放在很高的地方，他们够不到。我最喜欢的日托时刻可能是场景结束时，吉姆说任何人都可以走进去。杰瑞只是说，讲故事时间。
Story time is when Jerry poops every day. Yeah. No one's around. No one's coming in during the time. Story time. Well, I'll have you know at 15 minutes, 25 seconds, you can see kids out the door over John's shoulder. So they are there, just proof of child.
讲故事时间是杰瑞每天拉屎的时候。是的。周围没人。那个时间没人进来。讲故事时间。好吧，我告诉你，在15分25秒，你可以看到约翰肩膀后的门外有孩子。所以他们确实在那里，只是证明有孩子。
Proof of child. Also, this whole storyline of Jim walking in on the guy in the bathroom was based on a real-life moment. This is so good, Jenna. You have to tell it. From our writer, Halstead Sullivan. Halstead and Warren both brought so much of their personal stuff. I know.
证明有孩子。另外，吉姆在洗手间撞见那个人的整个故事情节是基于现实生活中的一个时刻。这太棒了，珍娜。你必须讲出来。来自我们的编剧哈尔斯特德·沙利文。哈尔斯特德和沃伦都带来了很多他们个人的东西。我知道。
Halstead said he was on a college tour with his father, and they were visiting Williams College in Massachusetts. And the admissions office was a small house that had been converted into offices. And while Halstead was waiting for his interview, he decided maybe he should run to the bathroom really quickly. So he went to the bathroom, which he described as just a typical bathroom that you would find in any house. He opened the door, and he said, quote, he was suddenly face-to-face with a man sitting
哈尔斯特德说他和父亲去大学参观，他们正在参观马萨诸塞州的威廉姆斯学院。招生办公室是一栋被改建成办公室的小房子。当哈尔斯特德等待面试时，他决定也许他应该快速跑去洗手间。所以他去了洗手间，他形容那只是你在任何房子里都能找到的普通洗手间。他打开门，他说，引用，他突然面对面看到了一个坐在
on the toilet who said, hello, Halstead said, I am so sorry, close the door, went back to wait for his interview. A few minutes later, when he was escorted to his interview, the man from the toilet was his interviewer. No, no, no. Yes. Oh, my Lord. Halstead said he was only 17 at the time, and he couldn't get out of his head during
马桶上的男人，那个人说，你好，哈尔斯特德说，我非常抱歉，关上门，回去等面试。几分钟后，当他被带去面试时，那个坐在马桶上的人就是他的面试官。不，不，不。是的。哦，天哪。哈尔斯特德说他当时只有17岁，他在面试期间
the interview. It's all he could think about was that this was the man from the toilet. He said he assumed that he flubbed the interview, so he didn't even end up applying to the school. He didn't even apply? No, he just scratched it off his list. He said years later, he pitched it as a storyline on the office, to which I said, I just love how you guys brought these real-life moments from your life, how they make their way onto the show.
脑子里一直挥之不去。他满脑子想的都是这就是那个坐在马桶上的人。他说他以为他搞砸了面试，所以他最后甚至没有申请那所学校。他甚至没申请？不，他只是把它从名单上划掉了。他说多年后，他在《办公室》里把它作为一个故事情节提了出来，对此我说，我真的很喜欢你们如何把这些现实生活中的时刻带入节目，它们是如何进入节目的。
And he said, you know what? You make all kinds of confessions when it's midnight, and you're just trying to think of a story so you can go home. And I thought, what fun would it be to be in the writer's room at midnight when I am? 11.45, it goes down. What is being told? What is being said? So much.
他说，你知道吗？当是午夜时，你只是想出一个故事以便回家，你会做出各种忏悔。我想，在午夜时分待在编剧室里会是多么有趣。11点45分，事情发生了。在讲什么？在说什么？太多了。
Well, Michael has decided to go to the one man he thinks has all the answers, David Wallace. And he says he doesn't like him stopping by unannounced, but who does? Except today, David Wallace is like thrilled to see Michael. So happy. He answers the door, he's unshaven. His son is playing drums in the background, and David's like, come on in. Let's have lunch. Amazing.
好吧，迈克尔决定去找他认为拥有所有答案的那个人，大卫·华莱士。他说他不喜欢他没打招呼就顺道拜访，但谁喜欢呢？除了今天，大卫·华莱士见到迈克尔很高兴。太高兴了。他开了门，他没刮胡子。他的儿子在背景里打鼓，大卫说，进来吧。我们吃午饭吧。太棒了。
At 13 minutes 43 seconds, when you see that establishing shot of David Wallace's house, you'll recognize it. We've been there before in the show. Per Randy Cordray, we rented this house for the day, and it was in Encino, California. Lady, did you just give us a location alert? Oh, I guess I did. Wow, well done. Oh, look at me, fast-facking and location alerting.
在13分43秒，当你看到大卫·华莱士房子的那个建立镜头时，你会认出它。我们在节目中去过那里。根据兰迪·科德雷的说法，我们租了这栋房子一天，它在加利福尼亚州的恩西诺。女士，你刚才给了我们一个地点警报吗？哦，我想我给了。哇，干得好。哦，看看我，快速事实和地点警报。
What is happening? I don't know. Should I look through my digital clutter? Yes, please. All right, I will. OK, I'll be excited. Next week, watch out. Jenna's digital clutter.
发生了什么？我不知道。我应该翻翻我的数字杂物吗？是的，请。好吧，我会的。好的，我会很兴奋。下周，小心。珍娜的数字杂物。
So they're going to go into the kitchen, and David's going to start making some lunch. 14 minutes, 21 seconds. Jenna, did you see what he's using to make a sandwich with? Is it whipped marshmallow? It's marshmallow cream, like marshmallow fluff and peanut butter. Have you ever had this? It's called a fluffer-nutter. What?
所以他们要进厨房，大卫要开始做午餐。14分21秒。珍娜，你看到他用什么做三明治了吗？是搅打棉花糖吗？是棉花糖奶油，就像棉花糖绒和花生酱。你吃过这个吗？这叫“Fluffer-nutter”。什么？
It is. It's called a fluffer-nutter. I'm sure that it is called that. It is called a fluffer-nutter. I'm just saying, you know what a fluffer is, right? A fluffer-nutter? Get your mind out of that gutter, lady. I just said fluffer-nutter.
是的。它叫“Fluffer-nutter”。我肯定它叫那个名字。它叫“Fluffer-nutter”。我只是说，你知道什么是“fluffer”吧，对吧？“Fluffer-nutter”？把你的思想从那个阴沟里拿出来，女士。我只是说了“Fluffer-nutter”。
I'm spraying to mind. That's what she said. I'm sorry. Earlier, you said the best wiener in Scranton, and I didn't say a word. I wanted to, and I said, no, keep it professional, Kenzie. I'm sorry. Go on. Okay.
我正在喷洒思想。这就是她说的。对不起。早些时候，你说斯克兰顿最好的热狗，我一句话也没说。我想说，我说，不，保持专业，肯齐。对不起。继续。好的。
I have clearly not heard this term. Okay. Well, the first time I ever had a fluffer-nutter was in Connecticut. What? What? What? Stop. I didn't laugh a single time.
我显然没听过这个词。好的。好吧，我第一次吃“Fluffer-nutter”是在康涅狄格州。什么？什么？什么？停。我一次都没笑。
You said wiener. All right, we have to pause while my friend gets it together. Okay, go ahead. You had a fluffer-nutter letter in Cleveland. Where were you? Connecticut. Connecticut. My first fluffer-nutter was in Connecticut.
你说了热狗。好吧，我们得暂停一下，等我朋友冷静下来。好的，继续。你在克利夫兰吃过“Fluffer-nutter”。你在哪？康涅狄格州。康涅狄格州。我的第一个“Fluffer-nutter”是在康涅狄格州。
I was visiting family with the Liebersteins. I'm sorry. Am I the only one? Sam, please. Oh, my gosh. Cassie is fine. Okay, go ahead. You had a fluffer-nutter in Connecticut.
我和利伯斯坦一家去探亲。对不起。我是唯一一个吗？萨姆，请。哦，天哪。卡西很好。好的，继续。你在康涅狄格州吃过“Fluffer-nutter”。
In Connecticut. With your whole family. With Warren and Paul Liebersteins. Oh, God. Okay. I had to know more about the sandwich. It's delicious. It's marshmallow cream and peanut butter.
在康涅狄格州。和你的全家。和沃伦与保罗·利伯斯坦。哦，天哪。好的。我必须了解更多关于这个三明治的事。它很好吃。它是棉花糖奶油和花生酱。
Okay. I was like, I've never heard of this. Is it an East Coast thing? And guess what? It is. Really? According to the internet, it's marshmallow cream and peanut butter. But marshmallow cream, one of the main ingredients of a fluffer-nutter, was invented in the
好的。我当时想，我从来没听说过这个。这是东海岸的东西吗？你猜怎么着？是的。真的吗？根据互联网，它是棉花糖奶油和花生酱。但是棉花糖奶油，“Fluffer-nutter”的主要成分之一，是在
early 20th century. Archibald Query invented a cream he called marshmallow cream in Somerville, Massachusetts in 1917. And during World War I, Emma Curtis published a recipe for what she called the Liberty Sandwich, which was peanut butter and her snowflake marshmallow cream on oat or barley bread. The recipe was published in a promotional booklet and sent to customers and may be the origin of the fluffer-nutter sandwich.
20世纪初发明的。阿奇博尔德·奎里于1917年在马萨诸塞州的萨默维尔发明了一种他称之为棉花糖奶油的奶油。在第一次世界大战期间，艾玛·柯蒂斯发表了一个食谱，她称之为“自由三明治”，那是花生酱和她的雪花棉花糖奶油涂在燕麦或大麦面包上。这个食谱发表在一本宣传册中并寄给顾客，可能是“Fluffer-nutter”三明治的起源。
I have used this marshmallow cream like when you make Rice Krispie treats. Of course. It's like a hack. It is. You don't have to melt a bag of marshmallows. The sandwich made with peanut butter and marshmallow cream continued to be eaten but was not called a fluffer-nutter until 1960 when an advertising firm that was working with this company, Durkey Moer, that owns marshmallow cream, thought it might be a more effective way to market
我用过这种棉花糖奶油，比如当你做米脆饼的时候。当然。这就像一个窍门。是的。你不需要融化一袋棉花糖。用花生酱和棉花糖奶油做的三明治继续被食用，但直到1960年才被称为“Fluffer-nutter”，当时一家与这家公司Durkey Moer（拥有棉花糖奶油）合作的广告公司认为这可能是一种更有效的营销方式
the sandwich. The sandwich has close ties to New England and Massachusetts, particularly Somerville. In fact, Somerville holds an annual festival called What the Fluff. Oh, OK. Got anything nasty you want to say about their festival, Jenna? No. Sam is giggling. The festival incorporates music, visual arts, games, and a cooking contest based around
三明治。这个三明治与新英格兰和马萨诸塞州，特别是萨默维尔有着密切的联系。事实上，萨默维尔每年举办一个名为“What the Fluff”的节日。哦，好的。关于他们的节日，你有什么刻薄的话想说吗，珍娜？没有。萨姆在咯咯笑。这个节日结合了音乐、视觉艺术、游戏和以
fluff and fluffer-nutters. And October 8th is National Fluffer-Nutter Day. Wow. There you go. Here's what I'm wondering. When did the term fluffer come around? Does it pre-date or post-date the advertising agency's naming of this sandwich? Well, it was named in the 60s.
Fluff和Fluffer-nutters为基础的烹饪比赛。10月8日是全国Fluffer-Nutter日。哇。给你。我想知道的是。Fluffer这个词是什么时候出现的？它是在广告公司命名这个三明治之前还是之后？嗯，它是在60年代命名的。
I'll let you go down that rabbit hole. I'll let you Google fluffer origin. I'm curious. I mean, you know, I feel like fluffers were around in the 70s. Maybe fluffer-nutter predates it. So it's just it's an unfortunate thing for the sandwich that there's another maybe meaning. And for the record, I'm giggling, you were familiar with a fluffer-nutter, right? This is something you knew.
我会让你去钻那个兔子洞。我会让你去谷歌搜索Fluffer的起源。我很好奇。我是说，你知道，我觉得Fluffer在70年代就存在了。也许Fluffer-nutter比它早。所以这只是对三明治来说不幸的事情，因为有另一个也许的意思。而且为了记录，我在咯咯笑，你熟悉Fluffer-nutter，对吧？这是你知道的东西。
The sandwich. Yeah. You were familiar with a bagel. I was by this time. For the record, that's why I'm giggling. No, no, no, no. For the record, I didn't know what a fluffer-nutter or a bagel was at all. They were all East Coast things, and I didn't know about them.
三明治。是的。你熟悉百吉饼。到这个时候我熟悉了。为了记录，这就是我咯咯笑的原因。不，不，不，不。为了记录，我根本不知道什么是Fluffer-nutter或百吉饼。它们都是东海岸的东西，我不知道它们。
I found out about a fluffer-nutter after I knew what a bagel was. Got it, got it, got it. I would love a segment where you just reveal foods that you came to know later in life. Well, clearly, you're coming to know a fluffer-nutter later in life. I am. I didn't know about this sandwich. I knew about a fluffer-nutter before you did. Just put it on record.
我在知道什么是百吉饼之后才发现Fluffer-nutter。明白了，明白了，明白了。我想要一个环节，你只是揭示你后来才知道的食物。好吧，显然，你后来才知道Fluffer-nutter。我是。我不知道这个三明治。我在你之前就知道Fluffer-nutter。把它记录下来。
It sounds maybe gross, but does it taste good? It's so good. It's so good. I want to put a sliced banana on it. Yeah, why not? Have you tried that? No, but I'm sure you'd love it. I bet at that festival, they deep-fried them, too.
听起来也许很恶心，但它好吃吗？它太好吃了。它太好吃了。我想在上面放一片香蕉。是的，为什么不呢？你试过吗？没有，但我肯定你会喜欢的。我敢打赌在那个节日，他们也把它们深炸了。
At what, the fluff? Yeah. Have you tried fluffer-nutter? I bet it's good. Back to the episode, one of my favorite exchanges of dialogue happens in this kitchen. Okay. Rachel, David Wallace's wife, walks in. Oh, yes.
在什么，Fluff？是的。你试过Fluffer-nutter吗？我敢打赌它很好吃。回到这一集，我最喜欢的对话交流之一发生在这个厨房里。好的。瑞秋，大卫·华莱士的妻子，走了进来。哦，是的。
This is so much about their relationship and what's going on in their marriage right now. She goes, hey, honey, how's your day going? Did you do anything cool? And he's like, no, sweetie, just sort of hung out. And she says, this is the line. This is it. I wrote it down as well. Because I saw you had shoes on, so I didn't know if you did anything.
这很大程度上是关于他们的关系以及他们婚姻中正在发生的事情。她说，嘿，亲爱的，你今天过得怎么样？你做了什么酷的事吗？他说，没有，亲爱的，只是闲逛。她说，这就是那句台词。就是它。我也把它写下来了。因为我看到你穿着鞋子，所以我不知道你是否做了什么。
Amazing. Amazing. Rachel Wallace was played by Jean Villapique. She was a member of Second City Improv Group. She's done a ton of comedy. You may have seen her on Veep, Key and Peel, Modern Family, Bojack Horseman. She's also a regular on AP Bio. I loved how she clocked the camera as she walked into her kitchen.
太棒了。太棒了。瑞秋·华莱士由简·维拉皮克扮演。她是第二城市即兴表演团的成员。她做了很多喜剧。你可能在《副总统》、《基和皮尔》、《摩登家庭》、《马男波杰克》中见过她。她也是《AP生物》的常客。我很喜欢她走进厨房时看摄像机的样子。
She's walking. She's like, oh, oh, hi, honey. She's also so happy to see Michael. Oh my gosh. What a switch. I know, right? At 14 minutes, 10 seconds, we see Teddy, David Wallace's son playing the drums. He was played by Owen Daniels.
她在走。她说，哦，哦，嗨，亲爱的。她见到迈克尔也很高兴。哦，天哪。真是个转变。我知道，对吧？在14分10秒，我们看到泰迪，大卫·华莱士的儿子在打鼓。他由欧文·丹尼尔斯扮演。
And you guys remember him. He was in the Cocktails episode in season three. Well, I remember talking to Suzanne Daniels about Owen's drumming. She was just having some mom pride about what a good drummer he was, and then here it got to be on the show. I know. So cool. Well, Michael and David are going to sit in the hot tub.
你们记得他。他在第三季的《鸡尾酒》一集中。好吧，我记得和苏珊·丹尼尔斯谈论欧文的打鼓。她只是对欧文是个多么好的鼓手感到妈妈的骄傲，然后在这里他能上节目。我知道。太酷了。好吧，迈克尔和大卫要坐在热水浴缸里。
This is so awkward. I mean, he says to his wife, we might go outside. Yeah. At 16 minutes, 55 seconds, Michael is wearing a t-shirt in the hot tub. And Jen Salata said this was because Steve was in such good shape that they had to hide his physique because it would have been distracting. Oh my gosh. Yeah.
这太尴尬了。我是说，他对妻子说，我们可能会出去。是的。在16分55秒，迈克尔在热水浴缸里穿着T恤。珍·萨拉塔说这是因为史蒂夫的身材太好了，他们不得不隐藏他的体格，因为那会让人分心。哦，天哪。是的。
That like you'd think, how is Michael in such good shape? Michael has like a 12 pack. Yeah. She also said it felt like this really great way to highlight how different David Wallace was being. That like David Wallace is just shirtless and relaxed. Drinking a beer. Yeah.
就像你会想，迈克尔的身材怎么这么好？迈克尔有12块腹肌。是的。她还说，这感觉像是突显大卫·华莱士有多么不同的一个非常好的方式。就像大卫·华莱士只是赤裸上身，很放松。喝着啤酒。是的。
In the middle of the day. Michael would be made like it would be more awkward for Michael to be in a t-shirt. We got a fan catch from Megan B and Potsville, Pennsylvania. In the hot tub scene, David Wallace is drinking a youngling lager. And Michael is drinking a youngling black and tan. Fast fact from Megan B. Youngling is America's oldest brewery and began right where I am from in Potsville, Pennsylvania. I looked it up.
在白天。迈克尔穿着T恤会更尴尬。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州波茨维尔的梅根B的粉丝捕捉。在热水浴缸场景中，大卫·华莱士在喝Youngling拉格啤酒。迈克尔在喝Youngling黑与棕啤酒。来自梅根B的快速事实。Youngling是美国最古老的啤酒厂，始于我所在的宾夕法尼亚州波茨维尔。我查过了。
It was founded in 1829. They are still brewing today. Megan would like to give a big shout out to the props department for yet again paying such close attention to detail by including a local beer that is most definitely found in many refrigerators in northeastern Pennsylvania. Nicely done, Phil Shea. I know. Megan would also like us to know, Angela, that if we ever come to Scranton, the youngling
它成立于1829年。他们今天仍在酿造。梅根想向道具部门大声致敬，因为他们再次如此密切地关注细节，包括一种在宾夕法尼亚州东北部的许多冰箱里肯定能找到的当地啤酒。干得好，菲尔·谢。我知道。梅根还想让我们知道，安吉拉，如果我们去斯克兰顿，Youngling
brewery tour is just about an hour away and it's really great. Maybe we can time that out and we'll hit the What the Fluff Festival and then go for a factory tour. I like it. Mm-hmm. Will I get through the What the Fluff Festival? I don't think you will. I think you're going to offend someone.
啤酒厂之旅大约只有一个小时的路程，而且真的很棒。也许我们可以安排一下，我们会去参加“What the Fluff”节日，然后去工厂参观。我喜欢。嗯哼。我能熬过“What the Fluff”节日吗？我不认为你会。我觉得你会冒犯某人。
Per Randy Cordray, the hot tub scene at 16 minutes 46 seconds was already there. We did not have to provide that. Hey. Hey there. We just used those people's hot tub? They did. Okay. Well, in this hot tub scene, Michael is trying to get David to give him ideas on how to deal
根据兰迪·科德雷的说法，16分46秒的热水浴缸场景已经在那里了。我们不需要提供那个。嘿。嘿，那里。我们只是用了那些人的热水浴缸？他们用了。好吧。好吧，在这个热水浴缸场景中，迈克尔试图让大卫给他一些关于如何处理
with Saber, but David is thinking about something else. He's thinking about a new company that he wants to start. It is a shop vac that will suck up kids toys. Mm-hmm. Does it make that noise? Who wants to know? Do the kids make that noise? Who makes that noise?
萨贝尔的想法，但大卫在想别的事情。他在想一家他想创办的新公司。这是一个会吸走孩子玩具的商店真空吸尘器。嗯哼。它会发出那种声音吗？谁想知道？孩子们会发出那种声音吗？谁发出那种声音？
Where's the noise coming from? And he tells Michael it's called Suck It. Writer Jen Salata told us that it was her mom that came up with the idea for Suck It. Come on. Yes. Jen Salata's mom had this idea. She thought it would be a very fun way to teach kids how to pick up their toys. That is adorable.
声音从哪里来？他告诉迈克尔它叫“Suck It”。编剧珍·萨拉塔告诉我们，是她妈妈想出了“Suck It”这个主意。拜托。是的。珍·萨拉塔的妈妈有这个主意。她认为这将是一个教孩子们如何捡起玩具的非常有趣的方式。这太可爱了。
So when she needed an invention for David Wallace, she thought of her mom's idea. And she said she thought it was perfect because since he's been home with his kids more often, he was probably frustrated with seeing their toys everywhere. It felt very organic. But how adorable is that? So cute. Well, lady, I decided to Google, how do you suck up toys? Okay.
所以当她需要为大卫·华莱士发明一个东西时，她想到了她妈妈的主意。她说她认为这很完美，因为自从他更频繁地和孩子们待在家里，他可能对看到他们的玩具到处都是感到沮丧。这感觉非常有机。但这有多可爱？太可爱了。好吧，女士，我决定谷歌一下，你怎么吸走玩具？好的。
I found an article by Newsweek in March of 2022. It talked about a guy who built a real-life Suck It for Lego pieces. Whoa. How cool is that? His name is Maddie Benedetto, and he posted the video. It shows him using a custom vacuum to collect pieces of Lego on the floor. Here's the ad. I invented the Lego Suck It, the world's first vacuum-powered Lego cleanup device that
我在2022年3月发现了一篇《新闻周刊》的文章。它谈到了一个为乐高积木制造了现实生活中的“Suck It”的家伙。哇。那有多酷？他的名字叫马迪·贝内代托，他发布了视频。它显示他使用定制真空吸尘器收集地板上的乐高积木。这是广告。我发明了乐高“Suck It”，世界上第一个真空驱动的乐高清理设备，它
automatically sorts each brick by its individual size. This vibrant cleaning accessory features a multi-stage chamber that magnetically separates for quick organization of your favorite toy bricks. The high suction vacuum will ensure every brick is sucked up from your floors and swiftly deposited into the clear tube as each Lego piece cascades down and gets sorted into their different sizes. So when things get messy, just suck it. How about that?
自动按每块积木的大小对它们进行分类。这种充满活力的清洁配件具有一个多级腔室，可以磁性分离，以便快速整理你最喜欢的玩具积木。高吸力真空吸尘器将确保每块积木都从你的地板上被吸走，并迅速沉积到透明管中，因为每块乐高积木都级联而下并被分类成不同的大小。所以当事情变得混乱时，就“Suck It”。那怎么样？
Wow. How many Legos have you stepped on? It's so painful. But how are you not sucking up everything on the floor? Like how is there not also a goldfish in there maybe? Oh, or a Cheerio. Exactly. I don't know.
哇。你踩过多少乐高积木？太痛苦了。但你怎么没有吸走地板上的所有东西？就像那里怎么可能没有金鱼？哦，或者一个Cheerio。正是。我不知道。
You have to have a clean Lego space. This is the thing. This is kind of the problem with David's invention, which is that, you know, yes, you're going to suck up the toys, but how do you avoid sucking up everything else? You just suck it. You just suck it. You just suck it. Well, Michael's going to leave David Wallace's.
你必须有一个干净的乐高空间。这就是问题所在。这是大卫的发明的问题，那就是，你知道，是的，你要吸走玩具，但你怎么避免吸走其他所有东西？你只是“Suck It”。你只是“Suck It”。你只是“Suck It”。好吧，迈克尔要离开大卫·华莱士家了。
He's so defeated. He says very few things would make him say no to working with David Wallace, but suck it is one of them. And then I love this shot of Michael slowly pulling away and David Wallace is sort of like lumbering down the driveway toward the car, like kind of like a zombie. It reminded me of a zombie movie. Jen Salata said this shot was John's idea, and I think it is some foreshadowing for a quiet place.
他太失败了。他说很少有事情会让他拒绝和大卫·华莱士一起工作，但“Suck It”是其中之一。然后我喜欢这个迈克尔慢慢开走的镜头，大卫·华莱士有点像僵尸一样沿着车道向车走去。这让我想起了僵尸电影。珍·萨拉塔说这个镜头是约翰的主意，我认为这是对《寂静之地》的一些预示。
No, really? I really do. It felt very horror movie to me. Right after this creepy goodbye with David Wallace would have come the final accounting scene in the runner that got deleted. Here's how it wraps up. Accounting area, interior office, Angela's looking over Kevin's work. Angela, who did this?
不，真的吗？我真的这么认为。这对我来说感觉非常恐怖电影。就在这个与大卫·华莱士令人毛骨悚然的告别之后，应该是被删除的支线中的最后一个会计场景。这就是它的结尾。会计区，内景办公室，安吉拉在看凯文的工作。安吉拉，谁做的这个？
Oscar shakes his head. Kevin, it's possible I did it on my own. Angela, no, it's not. That is the one thing that is not possible. How did this happen? Kevin, I did it. Angela sighs, confused, and walks away. Just missing Todd, who approaches with Kevin's adding machine.
奥斯卡摇了摇头。凯文，可能是我自己做的。安吉拉，不，不是。那是唯一不可能的事情。这是怎么发生的？凯文，我做的。安吉拉叹了口气，困惑地走开了。只是错过了托德，他带着凯文的加法机走过来。
Kevin looks nervous. Todd, you left this on my desk. Kevin, thanks. Todd and Oscar ad-lib hello's. And Todd leaves. Kevin, don't tell Angela. Oscar, I won't. Kevin, I didn't just let him do the work.
凯文看起来很紧张。托德，你把它留在我的桌子上了。凯文，谢谢。托德和奥斯卡即兴说了你好。然后托德离开了。凯文，别告诉安吉拉。奥斯卡，我不会的。凯文，我没有只是让他做工作。
I learned stuff. Please don't tell her. Oscar, I said I won't. Kevin looks nervous. Oscar looks up at him. Oscar, he trained me when I started here. Kevin, really? Oscar nods and Kevin smiles.
我学到了东西。请别告诉她。奥斯卡，我说我不会的。凯文看起来很紧张。奥斯卡抬头看着他。奥斯卡，我刚开始在这里工作时他训练了我。凯文，真的吗？奥斯卡点点头，凯文笑了。
What a sweet ending to that story. I know, and who is Todd at Vance for Fridgeration? I mean, it kind of sounded like maybe Todd used to work at Dunder Mithlin. I don't know. I feel like Todd is training people. Yeah. Anyway, I thought that was sort of sweet. Well, speaking of sweet, something we haven't talked about is that cutie pie scene at reception
那个故事的结局多甜蜜啊。我知道，托德在万斯制冷公司是谁？我是说，听起来好像托德以前在邓德米夫林工作过。我不知道。我觉得托德在训练人。是的。无论如何，我觉得那很甜蜜。好吧，说到甜蜜，我们还没谈到的是那个可爱的场景，在接待处
with Andy and Erin, where they're both not asking each other out on a date. It's a totally adorable scene. But if I'm being honest, I was very distracted by the fact that Pam's watercolor is back on the wall. It's all I could see. It's all I could see. I was just so delighted. Michael's going to return, and he's going to make a toast.
和安迪与艾琳，他们俩都没有约对方出去。这是一个非常可爱的场景。但如果我诚实的话，我被帕姆的水彩画回到墙上的事实分散了注意力。我只能看到那个。我只能看到那个。我太高兴了。迈克尔要回来了，他要敬酒。
He's brought a lot of orange juice. I guess in honor of Tallahassee. Florida. Yeah. Oranges. He makes his toast. It's not really a toast, but everyone takes a big swig, and they're like, oh. Yeah.
他带了很多橙汁。我想是为了纪念塔拉哈西。佛罗里达。是的。橙子。他敬酒。那不是真正的敬酒，但每个人都喝了一大口，他们说，哦。是的。
I mean, have you ever had orange juice out of like an aluminum container? A little tangy. Yeah. I mean, it goes right into your teeth, just like they talk about, but you know what? I don't think that a lot of people are putting their orange juice into metal containers. You know, it's really meant to be a water vessel. I like that you said vessel. Thank you.
我是说，你有没有用铝制容器喝过橙汁？有点刺鼻。是的。我是说，它直接进入你的牙齿，就像他们说的那样，但你知道吗？我不认为很多人把橙汁放进金属容器里。你知道，它真的是为了作为水容器。我喜欢你说容器。谢谢。
It's a water vessel. It is. Well, I guess this toast means that Michael is going to stay. He's going to stick it out at Saber. He is. He's going to, I guess, have to abide by all these new rules that he hates. No YouTube for Michael at work? I don't know how that's going to go.
它是一个水容器。它是。好吧，我想这个敬酒意味着迈克尔要留下来。他要坚持在萨贝尔工作。他是。我想他将不得不遵守所有这些他讨厌的新规则。迈克尔在工作时不能用YouTube？我不知道那会怎么样。
The episode ends with David Wallace and his son jamming out to a song that he's written called Suck It. Let's listen to it. Well, it's a math water man. What you going to do? You want to take out your suck it and your suck it. Suck it. Yeah.
这一集以大卫·华莱士和他的儿子演奏他写的一首名为“Suck It”的歌结束。让我们听听。好吧，这是一个数学水人。你要做什么？你要拿出你的“Suck It”和你的“Suck It”。“Suck It”。是的。
Take out your suck it and your suck it. Suck it. Yeah. Suck it. Oh, and Daniel's on the drums. I know, man. We got a fan question from Donna in Newport, New Virginia. Please tell us everything about the Suck It song at the end of the episode, How Much
拿出你的“Suck It”和你的“Suck It”。“Suck It”。是的。“Suck It”。哦，欧文·丹尼尔斯在打鼓。我知道，伙计。我们收到了来自新港，新弗吉尼亚州的唐娜的粉丝问题，请告诉我们关于这一集结尾的“Suck It”歌曲的一切，有多少
Was Improvised. I will tell you, Donna, the lyrics to Suck It were written by Warren and Halstead. These guys really were our go-to guys for song lyrics. And then I reached out to Andy Buckley, who plays David Wallace. He said that Warren and Halstead faxed him the lyrics the night before. Old tech alert, Angela. Fax. Yeah.
是即兴创作的。我会告诉你，唐娜，“Suck It”的歌词是由沃伦和哈尔斯特德写的。这些人确实是我们歌词的首选。然后我联系了扮演大卫·华莱士的安迪·巴克利。他说沃伦和哈尔斯特德在前一天晚上把歌词传真给了他。旧技术警报，安吉拉。传真。是的。
They faxed them. He went over them that night. He went over them at lunch the next day. That's when he was able to kind of fiddle around on a keyboard. He said he only knew about three chords on a keyboard. But he did his best. They did not shoot this until the very end of the day. They only had three minutes before they went into overtime.
他们传真了。他那天晚上看了看。第二天午餐时他看了看。那时他能够有点在键盘上摆弄。他说他只知道键盘上的三个和弦。但他尽力了。他们直到一天结束才拍摄这个。他们在加班前只有三分钟。
Three minutes. Yes. No messing up. Yes. He said it all came together when Owen started playing the drums. It was kind of a magic moment. They got it in three takes. He said that the whole shoot day was a total blast.
三分钟。没错。不能搞砸。没错。他说当欧文开始打鼓时，一切都水到渠成了。那真是一个神奇的时刻。他们拍了三条就过了。他说整个拍摄日都非常愉快。
He loved John as a director. He said John just had tons of positive energy and that John and Jen Salata worked so well together. He sort of remembered that someone would do a take and then you'd see them kind of huddle and giggle and then they would come over with some great idea. That's my memory too. Same. Andy said that inevitably, if he is walking through an airport or some public place, there
他很喜欢约翰作为导演的表现。他说约翰总是充满正能量，而且约翰和简·萨拉塔合作得非常默契。他记得有人拍完一条后，他们会聚在一起窃窃私语，然后带着很棒的点子走过来。这也是我的记忆。我也是。安迪说，不可避免地，如果他走在机场或公共场所，总会
is always someone who yells out, suck it. He also said that he and Zach Woods are now on an HBO comedy called Avenue 5 and it films in London. Amazing. He said they were in London for four months before the pandemic in the summer of 2019 and they just went back this past fall in 2021. He said that the difference between people stopping the two of them before the pandemic and after the pandemic is striking.
有人对他大喊“去死吧”（Suck it）。他还说他和扎克·伍兹现在正在拍一部HBO的喜剧《第五大道》，在伦敦拍摄。太棒了。他说在2019年夏天疫情爆发前，他们在伦敦待了四个月，去年2021年秋天他们又回去了。他说疫情前后人们拦住他们两人的情况有着显著的差异。
He said clearly a lot of people binged the office during the pandemic. He's getting way more suck it. Lately. Well, I hope that's a good thing. I think so. Well that is the Saber episode. Well before we go, I thought we could end this episode with a few final thoughts from John about what directing this episode meant to him.
他说很明显很多人在疫情期间刷完了《办公室》。最近他听到“去死吧”的次数多多了。嗯，我希望这是件好事。我想是的。好了，这就是《赛博》那一集。在结束之前，我想我们可以用约翰关于执导这一集对他意味着什么的一些最后想法来结束这一集。
This show was my film school. I mean, I was a waiter before I got the show. I had zero experience in this business in anything, acting, writing, directing, producing any of that stuff. And there it was right in front of me. I was somehow lucky enough to drop right into the most immense pool of talent that I could ever ask for from that insane group of people that we had as our writers. A group of people that hadn't been assembled like that in a long, long time, I guess.
这部剧是我的电影学校。我是说，在接这部剧之前我还是个服务员。我对这个行业一窍不通，无论是表演、写作、导演、制片还是其他任何东西。但它就摆在我面前。我不知何故幸运地掉进了我所能要求的最大的人才库中，那群疯狂的编剧们。我想，那是一群很长很长一段时间以来都没有这样聚集在一起的人。
And you know, in a lot of ways, probably hasn't been assembled since. So from writing, I got to understand what it meant to not only write well, but to have fun with it and to have this drive to do something great. I remember going up to the writers rooms every now and again, if I had a break between scenes or something and, you know, watch them all come up with an idea. And the idea was almost like you could visualize a balloon in the air and 12 to 14 people were making sure it didn't touch the ground before they had investigated every single possibility of how to make it work and how to make a joke work or an idea work.
你知道，在很多方面，可能从那以后就再也没有这样聚集过了。所以从写作上，我不仅理解了什么是好的写作，还学会了从中寻找乐趣，并有了做大事的动力。我记得偶尔在场景间隙休息时，我会去编剧室，看着他们想出点子。那个点子就像你可以想象空中的一个气球，12到14个人确保它不会落地，直到他们研究了所有让它奏效、让笑话或点子奏效的可能性。
And even if it didn't end up working, they still put it on a different board that was like, well, it's not working today, but maybe it'll work again on another day. And if it did work, they all work together to try to figure out how it would best be used in this show. So writing wise, there I was front row seats in the greatest room I could be visually. I had no idea what even a camera was. I didn't know what the difference between lenses were. I didn't know what type of cameras did what, but I remember there again, the office was
即使最终没成功，他们也会把它放在另一块板子上，意思是，好吧，今天不行，但也许改天再试。如果成功了，他们会一起努力找出它在剧中最好的呈现方式。所以写作方面，我坐在最好的房间里的前排座位。视觉上，我甚至不知道什么是摄像机。我不知道镜头之间有什么区别。我不知道什么类型的摄像机是做什么用的，但我记得，同样，《办公室》是
shot single cameras, one of the first shows to be done and like that in a long time. And so we were shooting the show like a movie. So I got to pick the brain of Randall and Matt and all these hugely talented people who would explain to me everything from lenses to the aesthetic and lighting and all these different things that I had absolutely no idea about. After Dark and Saber, I used to hang out with Dave Rogers and watch him cut all these different episodes. I'd go in and see how he was making all these scenes work, how he was rearranging story,
单机位拍摄的，这是很长一段时间以来第一批这样做的剧集之一。所以我们像拍电影一样拍摄这部剧。我有机会向兰德尔、马特和所有这些非常有才华的人请教，他们向我解释了从镜头到美学、灯光以及所有我完全不懂的事情。在《黑暗之后》和《赛博》之后，我经常和戴夫·罗杰斯待在一起，看他剪辑这些不同的剧集。我会进去看他是如何让这些场景奏效的，他是如何重新安排故事的，
how he was taking air out of a moment to make it work so much stronger. So really at the end of the day, I certainly would not be writing and directing at all if it wasn't for this show. I just, I wouldn't have had the confidence to do it. So I guess what I'm trying to say is I owe absolutely everything to this show. Everything this episode was so very special and I will truly never forget it. Thank you for having me on the show. I was so excited to come back and have me back again.
他是如何从一个时刻中删减冗余以使其更强有力的。所以归根结底，如果不是因为这部剧，我肯定根本不会从事写作和导演工作。我只是没有信心去做。所以我想说的是，我绝对欠这部剧一切。一切。这一集非常特别，我真的永远不会忘记。谢谢你们邀请我参加节目。我很高兴能回来，也谢谢你们再次邀请我。
But again, like I said, slow down. We need more of this podcast, please. John Krasinski, we love you. Love you so much, John. That was so generous of you. You shared so much with us and I just loved hearing your voice. Same. I also want to give a big thank you to Yaki Margolies for that amazing Beach Boys parody.
但再说一次，就像我说的，慢点。我们需要更多这样的播客，拜托。约翰·卡拉辛斯基，我们爱你。非常爱你，约翰。你太慷慨了。你和我们分享了这么多，我真的很喜欢听你的声音。我也是。我还要非常感谢雅基·马戈利斯带来的那段精彩的《海滩男孩》模仿秀。
You can find him on Twitter and Instagram at Yaki Margolies and you can listen to his music online anywhere that you get your music, like Spotify, Apple Music, iTunes, etc. I also want to say thank you to Joya Balfour for sharing with us what NBC Digital was up to and to Randy Cordray and Lauren Leverstein and Halstead Sullivan. Thank you, everyone. We will see you next week. I hope you enjoy a fluffer nutter this week. I'm going to have one.
你可以在推特和Instagram上找到他，账号是Yaki Margolies，你可以在任何获取音乐的在线平台收听他的音乐，比如Spotify、Apple Music、iTunes等。我还要感谢乔亚·巴尔福与我们分享NBC数字部门的动态，以及兰迪·科德雷、劳伦·莱弗斯坦和霍尔斯特德·沙利文。谢谢大家。我们下周见。希望你这周能享受一个棉花糖花生酱三明治。我也要吃一个。
Please do. I will. Okay. Oh, on gluten-free bread. Yay. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher.
请务必享用。我会的。好的。哦，用无麸质面包。耶。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔担任执行制片人。
Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码Office。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。